well to get great at anything you have
to be consistent or anything any skill
that you want to develop you have to be
consistent on at the beginning of a
journey it's okay to experiment and
taste and test and try and do a bunch of
things you know I made my first video
and I wasn't like the next day making
another video and the next day making
another video or it wasn't consistent at
the beginning and my growth reflected it
you know in year one I post on my
website where I'm at with subscriber
count year by year by year and year one
is like 25 subscribers and by year five
in my fifth year I'm still at 700
something subscribers it's not like I
took off and was blowing up right away a
lot of it was me sucking and not having
a skill but a lot of it was just lack of
consistency as well and that I wasn't
doing it every day there's a reason why
from all the people I've studied the
number one rule for Success that they
have is you have to love what you do not
just the end result of the thing that
you're doing but you have to love the
actual thing that you're doing it just
takes so much effort and so much time to
get world class at the thing that if you
don't love it you're gonna quit you kind
of have to be crazy doing it because you
just love it so much for most people
with quit that's how you end up winning
and so finding the thing that you you
love to do that you can stay consistent
on so that doesn't feel like work is the
thing that ends up getting you through
it like if you're hosting a podcast show
like this and you don't like
interviewing people do something else
don't do it because podcasting is a hot
Trend go do something else that you
really love to do we've made over 13 000
videos now in 13 years I've made videos
through tragedy and Trauma and the
broken neck and videos still went out
why because I love what I'm doing and
that's how I wasn't burning out and if I
stop liking making videos then I'll move
on to something else so the consistency
really matters but it's a lot easier to
stay consistent on the thing that you
actually love doing need motivation
Archer top 10.
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
carmackle and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
from me and my team's take on my top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two is find your core value
I think everybody has the single most
important core value
and when you figure out what that is it
allows you to live a more intentional
life so like if you had to pick what's
your most important core value oh man
Integrity it's a big one just being a
group period
uh I mean I mean that makes sense
knowing you and so now when you're
looking at you know who do I whether
it's in a relationship with somebody or
you're bringing on team if you're gonna
if you're gonna bring on a new video
editor for your team what most people do
is just think do they have the skills
that I need where for you that's not
enough they have to they have to be a
person of Integrity big time and when
you're around people of Integrity it
just allows everything to to flow more
right where you had the greatest video
editor of all time but they're they're
cutting Corners in line or whatever it's
not just about the results like how they
get it really matters to you and so it
changes the intention with which you
show up so if you're going to do a job
posting now for a video editor it's like
you post a video editor who believes in
Integrity like and that's the title and
some people will see that and say that's
the stupidest thing of all time who is
this guy like cool like don't apply
right like
self-eliminate thank you and others
would be like yes finally somebody's
speaking my language and so I think
everybody has a single most important
core value
and it's the job of finding out what
that is for you and so for me it's
believe and
that becomes the brand and that like a
brand is just an emotion so I want
people to leave everything that I make
with more belief I may not accomplish it
uh but it's the intention in everything
that I make and so if you could gift
Integrity To The World what a great what
a great gift to be able to create I like
it
um yeah so let's make sense rule number
three is aim to inspire let's go here
YouTube is is an education platform like
I think a lot of people think of it as
as entertainment and fun and movies and
music cool but YouTube is is the number
one education platform so you know
people are trying to figure out how to
become a more influential leader where
are they going to go they're going to go
to the library yeah who are they going
to talk to they're going to talk to
their mom like what they're going to go
and search and your stuff will pop up
and not just your videos but against
other people's videos this content that
people are going there to learn and so
YouTube is different than every other
platform
where we want to be making long-form
content teaching people because ahead of
whatever we're trying to sell we want to
put information we want to put education
okay we're teaching people at scale to
then bring them into whatever the thing
is that we're selling coaching products
program Services books Etc and the
beauty of something like YouTube is one
you're you're contentless forever so the
videos you make now in a year and two
years and six years are still getting
your views subscribers attention leads
Etc where every other platform it goes
away right like Instagram nobody cares
who you posted a week ago it's instant
it's Instagram it's gone
every other platform's the same YouTube
has the best monetization so they'll pay
you right like you could be making seven
figures just from the ad revenue on your
videos as well as actually building your
business
um and the best part about YouTube is
you can take the content since it's long
form and splice it up to put in all the
other platforms so YouTube will tell you
the best moments in every video
according to what the audience cared
about those little highlight moments you
can then tweak and put them to Twitter
and Instagram and Facebook and all the
other platforms so all you really have
to do is have a Regular Show long Chrome
on YouTube and now we're creating
content everywhere most of the people
listening watching your goal is not to
be a full-time just content creator you
got a business that you're trying to run
we're trying to build our membership
groups and our coaching services and be
a speaker and all of that stuff and so
you don't have time to all day every day
be on every single platform you don't
have to be long form from YouTube take
the data cut it up to be on every
platform so it kind of sits above all
the other social media platforms and
most importantly to help people's
message get out to change the world rule
number four is trust your ideas this is
where my perfectionist nature you know I
used to take over and slow me down so I
could get an idea and you get these
ideas and then your brain takes over and
you start researching like I gotta I
gotta make the perfect Plan before I
start don't make any mistakes so I'm
just gonna start what I've trained
myself to do
is two things
one
I tell myself that great ideas flow
through me
that great ideas will flow through me
because it came through me then it's a
great idea and what that does is kind of
shortcut the brain from over analyzing
over preparing and overthinking that as
long as you're in a good emotional state
right if you're like if you're
frustrated or pissed off or upset or
jealous
maybe don't trust the ideas that come to
you you know like if somebody cuts you
off in line or in traffic and you want
to go chasing like maybe think on that
one but but if you're in a in if you're
in a positive place if you're watching
this episode and you feel inspired or
hopeful or or you want to do more you're
grateful trust the ideas that come to
you because those ideas often don't make
sense like your next great idea doesn't
make sense
because your brain tries to make sense
of it but it doesn't make sense but your
heart wants to do it so it's it's
listening to your heart and just
trusting that great ideas flow through
you from there to get over the
perfectionism uh I would I came up with
what I call the two percent difference
so what most people do is focus on how
do I plan to 100 I'm going to start a
podcast so I need to have look at Alan's
setup he's got the TVs and he's got the
microphone and he's got the right and
people would look at that I need all
that before I start the two percent
difference is if you trust a great ideas
flow through you then what's the first
two percent
what's the first two percent that you
can do right now just to get started and
don't expect it to be perfect expect it
to suck but momentum for most people is
the only thing that's missing
we often use our best energy on planning
and so you come up with an idea and then
you plan and you plan and you plan and
plan you strategies and then a week goes
by and then you realize you don't have
the same courage and boldness that you
had a week ago and you spend all of that
great energy on planning instead of
doing where the first step should be to
do something
and then you start working on the plane
so if you want to work out you got to
get healthy or cool what's the perfect
workout plan well did you do hit do you
do cardio do you hire trainer you you go
to the gym and lift weights like what
are you gonna do there's so many options
the best thing to do is just do as many
push-ups as you can right now right you
get on the floor and you do five
push-ups 20 push-ups like however many
you can do is that going to help you
long term get your result no it's just
one day of doing a thing but the it
solves the most important problem which
is momentum because if you do 10
push-ups today then you can do 12
tomorrow you could do 14 the next day
you could do 20 the next day and then as
you start applying maybe you realize hey
push-ups aren't the thing maybe you
should be doing pull-ups maybe you
should be doing yoga maybe right like
the plan always changes just like we
talked about the Allen from five years
ago could not plan to where the island
is right now the plan will always change
but the biggest thing that's missing for
most people is just momentum so trust
that great ideas flow through you and
then apply the two percent difference to
just get started also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is believe in
yourself whatever you think the problem
is with cancer or or whatever like well
I think you know I think the woman who
solves cancer would have solved it by
now but she's a she's a manager at an
accounting firm hating her life because
she never either didn't didn't go to
medical school or never even thought
about it or uh just never chase it down
like I think everybody has what I call
Michael Jordan level genius at something
you're the greatest in the world at
something and we either don't believe in
that or we don't chase it down and we
end up living a life that is less than
what it could be and so even me I mean
my biggest problem is a lack of belief
to get to the next step and so that's
what I wake up every day trying to solve
um you know never gonna do it and I wake
up every day trying to do it rule number
six is build access to community who's
watching a YouTube video for three hours
the the entire world right like think
about if you're going to teach if you're
gonna make a video talking about how do
you become an influential leader where
am I going to learn that from nobody and
the people who are sharing it like go to
YouTube and search people are talking
about it are they as good as Rory Vaden
on that topic no it's like someone who
came from Instagram and you know they're
25 years old and still trying to figure
it out but they're gaining a lot of
traction and attention because people
like you who actually know what they're
talking about aren't on the platform so
there's giant demand and consumption and
very little very little Supply period
and and almost no quality Supply so like
am I too early am I too late on YouTube
we're just getting started inside of
Education uh so if I wanted to learn how
to become that influential leader
if you did a four minute video how much
you're gonna teach me in four minutes
not a lot but if you talk for an hour or
you did a coaching session with somebody
or you had a guest coming on sharing
something people would watch that
because it's the best thing there
available and then when you've got your
next launch your book your course your
program your private membership like I
love this Rory guy nobody's talking like
him how do I get more of him and they
want to pay for the access to get into
everything that you're offering and so
you don't worry about giving away too
too much there I mean like uh I mean how
many of those videos is it is it kind of
more like have one really killer two
hour video
or are you trying to like crank because
to do that every week would be pretty
tough not to mention you know if you did
an hour-long video every week that'd be
that'd be a lot of content
um like what would you be charging for
if you were giving away that much so is
it kind of like have a couple key key
trainings out there and do it that way
or
it depends what game you're playing uh
often the best thing to sell is access
so the best thing to sell is access to a
community uh so if you're trying to sell
your your program your community which
is awesome I was able to you know had
the honor to speak in front of if you
had a lot of long-form content that was
getting millions of views you're gonna
convert a lot of those people to want to
spend more time with you because they
love how you think like you're you're a
weird duck you think differently than
other people like I want to think the
way Rory thinks and I want to be around
him more often so I want to join his
community
um it's less about the actual ideas a
lot a lot of people have paid programs a
lot of the same content is in the
YouTube video as in the paid program
it's just packaged all together so it's
easy to find it's sequential there's
Community there's access and so that's
really what we're selling not just the
information I'm I put out I'm giving you
everything I got nothing to sell here
I'm giving you the best like you're
asking me questions this is what I do is
what I teach people will still some of
the names that you mentioned want me
need to help them with their Channel I'm
telling them the same thing that I'm
telling you guys right now here on Rory
vaden's show right so that I think
builds credibility builds trust and it
makes people want to have a deeper
relationship with you and buy all your
stuff rule number seven is serve I think
ultimately we're all built to serve Eric
right like we all want to serve we all
want to wake up and feel like we're
going to do something today that matters
and some days we feel like we're going
to change the world like if you're
listening to Eric's show you want to
have a big impact you want to change the
world you want to you want to have big
ripples across the planet right I mean
that's that's why you're here but some
days that feels too big and some days
like I'm never going to change I can't
do that it's too big a mission cool but
you can help one person
yeah or what about like yourself
yeah definitely like whatever you need
whatever you want to give to the world
you still need yourself
I think though at the end of the day you
want you want to feel like what you're
doing is helping somebody else like if
you're only chasing down selfish
Pursuits you won't end up being happy
like the happiness will come from
serving others in some capacity either
on some Grand scale or or even just
knowing that you made an impact on one
person today somehow I I don't think
it's possible to feel down and negative
and low and have a terrible self-esteem
if you are actually helping something
like when somebody says thank you so
much you really helped me even if it's
that little moment the 10 seconds of
like the brightness and enjoying your
life because you did something that
helped somebody else out and so that's
always a path like we want to feel like
what we do matters is important to
somebody else
um and that's what if you can connect to
that this is hard right you might have
the greatest day of all time today is
great I'm talking Eric it's amazing here
we go we're changing the world but let's
do it let's go Eric let's go tomorrow
and it's like it's you're back to square
one you know it's like it's a it's a
it's like brushing your teeth you have
to do it every day you have to find a
way to connect to the mission that
you're on to connect the serving people
every single day otherwise it's an easy
slippery slope down tube
uh you know apathy and uh if you keep
going down stress and anxiety and
depression and suicide because you feel
alone and you feel like you don't matter
and you feel like the work you do
doesn't matter you know like when you
feel like what you do doesn't matter the
next step becomes I don't matter and
when you're in I don't matter that's a
really dangerous Zone to be in and so
the path out is service helping every
day rule number eight is prioritize
quality the editing Almost Doesn't
Matter
like why are people listening to you
because like if we think about quality
content it people default the production
quality like oh what microphone using
their Rory and what's your headset and
like what's the lighting but nobody's
watching your stuff for your microphone
so the quality isn't production quality
it's quality of thought
can you teach me to think like you think
and so the mistake a lot of people make
is they if they're doing it themselves
at the beginning a lot of people do this
you spend 20 minutes uh making a video
and then five hours editing it
you're training the wrong skill
you're training yourself to learn an
editing software as opposed to training
yourself to be a better speaker where
your ultimate goal should be to be a
better speaker train spend five hours
making a video and 20 minutes editing it
or zero time editing it because the
ability to communicate your message in
front of a camera will be a skill set
you use for the rest of your life
whether YouTube exists or not when we're
beaming into your your living room in VR
and eight Holograms and all that you're
still just talking with camera
and so that ability to get your message
out there is the thing to train and
practice so I wouldn't worry about
editing being the most important thing
train yourself to be a great speaker
train yourself to press record deliver a
fire message and then release that as a
video because when you when I go live on
a podcast like this when I get up on
stage when I'm doing interviews there's
no edits I mean maybe if I really mess
up Rory will do me a solid and like cut
out that piece but we get on stage
there's no edits like you can't train
yourself as if you're a speaker you
can't train yourself to only communicate
when you're perfectly edited
yeah so we have to train ourselves to be
great it doesn't mean that you
completely disrespect the editing but my
goal would be to hey let's get your
business up to the point where the
content is helping you generate enough
money whether it's through your coaching
or your books or your programs so that
then you can afford to hire an Editor to
take it to the next level but the
editing will not save you it's quality
of thought more than production quality
rule number nine is start small this is
like the only thing I had going for me
you know like I wasn't I wasn't super
smart I wasn't charismatic I was not
getting any you know real success like 2
000 subscribers five years in
um the only thing I had going for me is
I always focused on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't yeah
so for me it's like if I had 50 people
watch the videos like 50 people watching
a video I think it's pretty cool right
like those are 50 real people who saw
that like if you were gonna go give a a
speech at a library or something and 50
people showed up at least for me at the
beginning I'd be super nervous and
excited to go off and do that but when
it's online we feel like we're some kind
of failure and I'm ambitious and I want
to grow and I want to have a huge impact
and it's great to chase numbers
um but I just always focus on who I was
actually helping I think that leads to a
lot more satisfaction doesn't lead to
doesn't mean you stay complacent and and
only like gratitude doesn't mean that
you have to stay stuck but it it makes
you feel more connected to impact you
know like we all want to wake up and
feel like today is going to matter that
we're going to do something today maybe
we're going to make something that hits
a million people or maybe we do
something that just touches one person's
life but we want to feel like today is
going to matter in some way and that's
what I always just if I saw 50 views on
the videos like this is weird and Rule
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is shift your
perspective I feel sometimes like okay
one one piece of the puzzle is for
example going and it's kind of slowing
down and I'm I'm feeling a little bit
exhausted so I want to like turn and
pivot into something that also excites
me and it's a different kind of hobby
different interest different excitement
right so it's like one thing I'll be
talking about you know leadership
development or the other and then all of
a sudden I'll be curious about fashion
and want to like navigate those two
polarities so that I'm constantly
feeling like I'm adding value in
different Industries
well here's the thing I would I would um
encourage a perspective shift for you to
see that those are not actual polarities
okay so Insight but this is the
challenge we have so inside of
leadership and fashion
what actually connects them like what's
the core value that you have the
expression for me
but yeah so so expression Eric is all
about expression yeah and and it's how
do you express yourself better and and
how do you allow others to express
themselves better like if somebody said
Eric man I listen to your show or watch
you or I had a conversation with you and
you gave me the permission to express
myself fully
that's like the greatest thing you could
hear from somebody I love it right yeah
so yeah to me this but it's the job
though for you then becomes to be able
to communicate expression through the
work so it's not if somebody just looked
at the content he's talking about
leadership over here he's talking about
fashion over here it feels like it's all
over the place
because you haven't done the job and I
mean I haven't seen all your con so I'm
just you know putting that on but when
you can do the job to explain that it's
expression
then it all makes sense then I'm
watching Eric not just for leadership
tips I'm watching Eric to figure out how
can I express myself better in all areas
of my life there's this great interview
with Jay-Z where he was talking about
somebody asked him reporter asked him
like how do you how do you move from
from rapping to Fashion to being an
entrepreneur and it's like it's all it's
just all about I think expression might
have been is either expression or
creativity it was like it was it because
it is
your energy changes how you show up
when you are happy positive optimistic
full of life Creative Energy you you
make amazing things
but when you feel negative down
depressed side for yourself low energy
you know you don't make amazing things
and this is not
something new that I'm telling you you
know this
the challenge is we are not in a high
energy state
consistently enough to stay consistent
on our goals so follow through to create
the momentum because we allow outside
forces as well as our internal voice to
keep us small to keep us protected to
keep us scared to depress our courage
muscle
and then even though you have great
ideas and great Ambitions and a great
heart and a desire to serve it doesn't
happen it doesn't happen because
the energy isn't connected to it if
you've got
a big idea
but low energy
nothing happens
you don't follow through and you end up
seeing other people with a worse version
of your idea but just more energy and go
off and do it have you ever seen it
happen you ever seen somebody
make tons of money have a huge impact
off of your idea somebody with less
heart and less vision and less
creativity but they just they just did
it they just got started they just took
action and just stayed consistent in
their energy and they made it happen and
you didn't because you allowed the
energy to dip
and so if energy is so important then
how do we how do we manage your energy
how do we keep it high and doesn't mean
that you always have to be on top of the
world and you don't have to delude
yourself and say I'm amazing this is
going to be the greatest day of all time
like you don't
doing things that you don't believe
won't help you get the energy that you
need because you'll do those things say
This is BS this isn't working
you don't always have to be in Peak
energy
but what you didn't need to do is be in
the right energy to serve your mission
and whatever you're doing today so let
me use me as an example and today
it's a great example because I did not
sleep well last night had had two and a
half hours sleep just tossing and
turning and
just could not could not get to sleep so
I slept from like 6 30 to 9 o'clock did
not sleep until 6 30 in the morning and
that is thankfully a rare occurrence you
know most nights I get eight hours sleep
seven and a half to eight and a half
hours sleep
but
on a day like today when I woke up and
did not have a ton of energy I did not
wake up and say yes I feel like crushing
it let's go and
I didn't want to do something I would
feel fake and disingenuous because if
you don't believe it then it's not going
to happen anyway so what did I do well
first off videos have to happen today
because that's part of my identity right
so momentum has to happen
so if you start to train yourself when
you create a calendar and say okay
today is a blank I'm filming this on a
Tuesday today's a Tuesday Tuesday's my
video day no matter what I'm filming
videos I gotta film videos it's got to
happen it may not be my best video
but I'm going to show up and give it my
the best that I've got the best energy
this is this is a lot lower energy than
I would normally show up with a video
but it's a different vibe it's a
different kind of energy and hopefully
it still serves and maybe maybe you like
and connect more with this energy then
I've been yelling in the car I don't
know but videos have to happen first off
second get outside you know get outside
get fresh air get some sun on my face if
you you know you want to change your
energy you want to shift where you're at
and how you're thinking because it's
part physical energy but also just
mental energy how do you feel about what
you're doing and what's going to happen
today and getting out of your home
changing your physical environment and
getting some sun on your face
can make a huge difference so every
morning I have my believe walk and I'm
walking around the park getting some
green getting some sun hopefully it's
not raining today's a beautiful day and
everybody it starts to make you feel a
little bit happier a little bit more in
the right energy space
music is a great way to change your
energy and often what we do is we put on
songs that make us feel how we currently
are so if you feel sad you put on a sad
song If you feel low you put on a low
song you feel chill you put on a Chill
song
where what we want to do is if you want
to change your energy put on the song
that matches that energy
if you want to feel happier upbeat put
unhappy or beat songs I have a playlist
on my channel called believe all caps on
the on the letters believe
that's all the songs that I listen to
and every day I've got that playlist
going I pick a random song and it just
starts playing and they're all songs
that if they came on it would make me
move
and when you move you start to change
your energy
what I'm trying to do is again not
create some fake energy but something I
can actually connect with I'm putting on
songs that I actually like I actually
like having some sunshine on my face you
know I actually like doing the work that
I'm about to do
but it requires you showing up with a
certain level of energy
and then the last one is
you know who you're feeding your mind
with who are you around who you're
surrounded by both the people in your
life you know actual humans
and the videos that you watch or books
that you read and podcasts you consume I
remember um on the weekend
and you got a guard against us it's
crazy so on the weekend I went to go
meet an old family friend
and
he just had
a lot of limiting
beliefs about him and what he's creating
and where he wants to go and it wasn't
it wasn't meant to be a coaching session
I'm not there to help him but just a
really negative low energy on a weekend
and I'm you know that's not usually part
of my routine on the weekend and so I go
to meet him
and my whole day ended up being thrown
off until I caught it at night to say
why why am I so low and negative today
in comparison to what I would normally
be and I thought back that oh yeah you
know what ever since I went to see him I
was fine in the morning I went to see
him and had this negative ripple effect
you know like you could have a positive
ripple effect on people you watch a
video and it can have a positive ripple
effect on you but but there's negative
Ripple effects too
and the people who you're surrounded by
who you're hanging out with or you're
watching on YouTube or podcast Etc they
can have a negative ripple effect on you
as well
and so he had this
negative ripple effect on me that lasted
almost the whole day until I caught it
in the evening said this isn't what I
want
it's not even my voice it's like his
voice planted in me why am I feeling
this way thinking this way I don't like
it
and so it became a conscious choice and
I applied a lot of the same things I got
it I went outside went outside reset get
some fresh air it always helps me put on
some music songs that I actually like
not some fake song that somebody else
likes and says dance to this it'll make
you feel good songs that I actually like
there are some songs that if it came on
it would
make you move it doesn't mean you get up
and dance and go and crazy but
there's some songs that if it came on
you would Bob your head or you would tap
your feet or bounce your knee there's
some songs that just make you do that
right so put on one of those songs it
would naturally make you feel happier
so I did that too and then in terms of
just gardening against people I made a
note that hey the next time I go see
this person he's a he's a family friend
so the next time I go see him
uh which is not often but still the next
time I see him I need to remind myself
of this
you know that that I need to I need to
have my shield ready
I need to give love as much as possible
and I'm not going to allow his
negativity to to break my shield you
know to permeate through
and so the more that you can catch those
things
the more you'll stay in a more energetic
state
and all of this again is not trying to
force fake energy and have you feel like
you're doing something unnatural I think
it's actually the most natural thing of
all time I think getting sun is natural
I think smiling and being optimistic is
natural I think everything I think the
negativity inside your head was planted
there was put there by other people
that's what's unnatural when you were a
kid and smiley and happy had dreams to
the Future everything was possible
everything was hopeful
sure we had bad days but you were a
happy kid
and all of those dreams and positivity
get squashed out of us by other people
who hate their lives and so I think
having energy is actually the most
natural thing not every day has to be on
top of the world but having positive
energy is natural having sunshine and
leading to happiness is natural putting
on music and and dancing and moving
is natural
being around other positive optimistic
happy people when you're around them
you'll naturally be more positive
optimistic and happy and so it's about
finding what is a natural flow for you
that when you do these things
it brings out a better energy in you
it brings out a happier more positive
more optimistic you and if you know what
some of those things are
you can copy my list if you want some of
them right sunshine music videos
then put into your daily routine
put into your daily calendar every day
this has to happen
because if you did the thing just
imagine this you've had days when you
felt energetic and you've had days when
you didn't and every would everybody
would give you the the out right like a
day like today two and a half hours
sleep
everybody would give me the hours like
okay you don't have to do it
there are days when you need to bring
the energy
if you did that every day
just imagine for the next month every
day you did the thing that puts you in a
better energy state
but you're on top of the world and the
fake high every day but a better energy
state
you did the thing in the morning that
put you in a better energy State for the
next 30 days how much is your life
change
how much is how you show up change how
much is the work that you do change how
much does your bank account change how
much is the impact you're creating
change how much of a better father or
mother or husband or wife are you
because you're showing up with more
energy more positive energy I
am all by default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we haven't
trained in us from a young age our
parents our family our friends our
teachers think about who did you learn
about life from probably people who
didn't like their own life you know who
did you learn about careers from
probably people who did not have a great
career you know who barely are enjoying
what they're doing in their work and
they're living in scarcity mindset of
this is all I can do and that's what
we've learned from and you know guidance
counselors at school do they love what
they're doing I mean I think this is a
huge problem and we're stuck living
small and living scared and living as a
result way below our potential of what
we could do and who we could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problem when I wake up every day trying
to do trying to help trying to create
and so how do you how do you get out of
it well I think the starting point is
being around the people who are living
and doing the things that you want to do
I think the way to 10x your results is
not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially at the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverages busting through limited
beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working
harder working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wins without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
who never accomplish their goals who
don't end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both
so if you're not working hard then you
don't have a shot but assuming you are
working hard and you want a 10x again
then it's a shift in mindset and the
shift in living beliefs so how do you
identify the living beliefs how do you
figure out where it's holding your back
how do you break through the Paradigm
and hit a new level a lot of it is
environmental
you know the the current thinking that
you have was environmental it's your
parents and your family and your
guidance counselor and teachers and
family Etc that's environmental you've
adopted their beliefs and unfortunately
a lot of them are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably something a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever is more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people every day but
you know we can't so how do you do it
well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do
even for me I make these videos for
myself so that I can be around John
Ashraf and Warren buff and Elon Musk and
Oprah Winfrey Etc because they inspire
me to want to be bigger looking at Elon
Musk is an example the news of the day
right now as I'm recording this video is
he's looking at buying Twitter and when
somebody asked me yesterday on Instagram
do I think Elon Musk will buy Twitter
I said no I don't think you'll buy
Twitter but
it's probably not a good idea to
underestimate Elon Musk
in general right
you know lots of people have
underestimated him and he's proven them
wrong many many many times and I just
like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk logically if you're
thinking through it if you're if you
were running Tesla uh in SpaceX would
you have thought about buying Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks I'm much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at it hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if he
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles in his early life and he if he
can overcome that to get to where he's
at I see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove but the groove can also be a
rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expansive
you could be having exponential growth
if you change your environment to be
around the people who have expansive
thinking right so step one is just
through content through through
aspirational mentors what I call them an
Elon Musk a John Azeroth Oprah Winfrey
people who who you
may never meet but you can still learn a
heck of a lot from
step two is to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but what are some
changes you can make to your environment
what are some conferences or events you
can go to to be around the people who
think the way that you want to think to
inject some newness some creativity some
ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you were in that things that used
to make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
conference an event you come back I
wanna you ever gone away and come back
and wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come with new
ideas I get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just just think about if
you're just constantly stuck it doesn't
mean you have to go travel on vacation
it may mean you take up salsa dancing it
may mean you try a new hobby take that
idea that you've got and just go go to
it look at any events that are happening
in your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use uh
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful uh computer at the time with
with unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forwards only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class that you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at
but he wouldn't have known that unless
he dropped out of school and dropped in
on the calligraphy class so it's
changing the environments being a part
of new things it's it's not just staying
stuck in the same habit the same
routines and and same thing you're doing
constantly and that will inject newness
that will then allow you to be more
creative and create amazing
opportunities for your next goals so
step one is to be around aspirational
mentors to be around the people like an
Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey Etc watching
videos content interviews podcasts books
that make you feel better stronger more
courageous step two is to get out of
your comfort zone and go go to things
physical things travel more take take on
classes say yes go to conferences and
events just so that you expose yourself
to new ideas and opportunities and come
up with fresher ideas of what you could
do with your life and step three is to
to actually have humans in your life who
you're around who make you want to push
and do more and be better and this mean
hey if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
mover makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know some Movie Maker is
something else but being around other
people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really really struggled so find
other people who are on this journey
that you can do it with because when you
feel like you're doing it with other
people and you're not alone you'll be a
lot more productive a lot more effective
and have a lot more fun as well your
environment creates your energy
when you are at home and you are down
and you are out and you just stay home
and you never get any fresh air and you
never get people around you to push you
and make you feel like things are
possible then you stay stuck
and when you get outside or when you go
to an event and when you meet people
even if you're not there to learn even
if you haven't picked up anything at
that event just the fact that you got
out and you met people and you change
your environment and you got some
sunshine you make a world of difference
it is
incredibly difficult to be an
entrepreneur
it's hard
it's hard not just in that you're you
know not seeing results at the beginning
and you're trying to figure out how to
make money but it's also hard that
you're by yourself
you know and you doubt yourself and your
insecurities and fears and you don't
know if it's going to work out or not
it's really hard and so when you're
stuck doing everything on your own and
then the fears and the doubts in
security pain when you're by yourself at
home
that's the path down to the scary Lane
you know that's the path down to anxiety
and stress and depression and it's why a
big reason why we stay stuck and why we
start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop
and and can't stay consistent have you
ever been on that entrepreneur roller
coaster where you're motivated and
excited and things are great one day and
the next day you wake up and it's kind
of not so great anymore does that happen
to you that happened to me a lot that's
for sure in the early days I mean I quit
on my business partner because I wasn't
getting results and I just felt like a
loser felt like a total idiot because
nothing was working out
um
worst day of my life it wasn't I didn't
have the heart or the ambition to do
great things or didn't believe in the
company it's just it wasn't working out
nothing was working out and and I felt
terrible about it
and the big reason why is because I was
alone I was by myself I was alone
I didn't tell my friends I mean I guess
I had a business partner but I felt bad
talking about it with with him and
I stay stuck
and so it took me a bunch of years to
figure out
these things that I'm about to share
with you today about some hacks that
I've used to help me maintain the
momentum so let's dive in the first is
every morning I go for a believe walk
and the believe walk is just me going
outside and selling a rain or snow here
in Canada I go for a believe walk and on
that walk
it's just a way to start my day because
no matter how great a day I might have
today tomorrow I wake up and it's
another day even today was rough day I
only slept two and a half hours or
something last night so it's a very
non-typical day energy not where it
needs to be or usually is in the morning
and so first thing let's get up and
you know give us our a little bit of
Grace it may not be as great a day as as
we usually do but I'm gonna go for my
believe walk and just getting outside
just getting some fresh air on my face
just
you know having some sun with me just
not being in my my home
already starts to lighten the mood
already starts to give me more energy
and so every day I go for a believe walk
you know unless I am just completely
incapacitated and wake up get some sun
on my face wherever I am and get my
belief walking just think about what's
the kind of day I want to have you know
what's my intention for the day and try
to set that up
two try to go to events and to the idea
of you know buy tickets to things it
could be things that you don't care
about but it could also be things that
you actually you know you're going to be
around some people and every time I go
away to an event this is why you know a
pandemic has been hard because he's just
been sitting inside but every time that
I get to go away to some kind of event
whether I learn something there or not
from the speakers or the people there
I always come back with Renewed Energy
with renewed excitement with renewed
ideas even if you just go on remember
going on vacations you know you go on a
vacation and you sit on the beach and I
hate the beach you know I hate sitting
there on the beach I'll go and and sit
on the beach for one day and then all of
a sudden get bored of sitting on the
beach I want to do something and so I'm
then instantly pulling out my notebook
and coming up with ideas or reading
books and you come away refreshed even
though the goal wasn't necessarily
business but you get new ideas for your
business when you get out of your
routine your your
uh you know the routine is great but
when you feel like you're stuck then
adding a little bit of variety to it can
really help this is the balance that we
have to do as entrepreneurs we love
variety we love new we love we love
trying all sorts of new things but if we
don't stay consistent on something we'll
never accomplish our goals but if all we
do is do the same thing constantly and
we stay consistent on doing the same
thing we end up getting bored and hating
our business and now we just bought
ourselves a job so it's that constant
balance where if you haven't had any
variety for a while you need to add more
variety in and if you haven't had
consistency for a while you need to add
more consistency with this ebb and flow
that's part of being an entrepreneur
that time I think you need to build in
so
just scheduling time so you have your
believed watches I do every every
morning to set me up for the day and
then schedule in time to be able to go
off and uh just just not be at home you
know whether it's a conference or an
event a vacation just something to
refresh my mind
and then the third thing is just join a
community
it was one of the biggest things that I
missed was I had no Community I was
doing it all by myself and I'm being
introverted and being shy I don't
naturally seek out community community
and talking to people it's not something
that that is normally in my mind and I'm
nervous you know going up and talking to
people so it's harder for someone like
me and maybe someone like you to join a
community but man what a difference it
makes
I think of movement makers and this is
really the program I wish I had when I
was getting started you know movement
makers is yes advice for me and we meet
every two weeks and talk about your the
movement you're trying to build and
everything you're trying to create but
more than that is a connection Community
to each other that
if you want to be a thought leader you
are not by yourself think about what
you're trying to do if we think about
what I was trying to do like I'm the
only one who I know who's trying to do
this you know who are your friends who
are trying to make YouTube videos who
else is walking through this Mom making
content
right nobody so who do you know who's
doing what you want to do probably
nobody and who who do you know who's
doing what you want to do at a high
level and who's ambitious and hungry
probably nobody right like you are
probably the one who is the most kind
optimistic ambitious person around you
and so when you start to get around
other people who are like that as well
man what a huge difference it makes and
so
you can look at Movie Makers if you want
to be a thought leader but just in
general to find a community find a
community of people who are doing the
thing that you are trying to do even if
they haven't done it yet but they're
ambitious and they're hungry and they're
trying to do it
it changed your life
starting the business is really hard and
you know this if you're watching this
video you made it this far you know what
you know it's hard
the environment that you're around
is only partially supporting you
and when you can shake it up when you
can get outside and go for walks get
some sun on your face when you can get
out of your home and go to events and
just be around other people who are
doing things and when you can join a
community of people who are trying to do
something similar to what you're doing
it can make all the difference in the
world you've got a great idea
you're doing it for the right reason
you've got a noble cause and if you feel
like you have those energy dips where
one day you're on top of the world and
it's all exciting and then the next day
you kind of wake up and you're you're in
a rut
if that right continues on you know for
days or weeks it's a sign not that
you're on the but this isn't right for
you it's just a sign that you need to
add a little more variety and remind
yourself of who you are be the change
you want to see in the world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
as much as there's government and big
business I think it's entrepreneurs it's
us we're going to solve all the world's
problems because we see a problem and we
want to fix it we want to solve it
that's what we do that's the most
exciting part of being an entrepreneur
is that you're not waking up and driving
to some job that you hate where the work
you're doing does not matter has no
meaning and instead you get to do
something that is actually going to
touch somebody's life and that is
Meaningful to you right you get the pick
you get to decide you get to choose and
we're trying to make the world a better
place we're going to make money doing it
too but Mission first purpose first and
then making money along the way in
service of others and it's in that
combination of what you love doing with
what brings value to other people that
you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough right it's like have
you had a hard time managing yourself
have you had a hard time sticking to
your routines and keeping to your
motivation and staying strong on the
things that you say you're going to do
like self-management self-leadership is
hard enough now we're going to go off
and lead other people as well and where
do we learn about leadership we don't go
to school for this we don't have
programs we don't probably have great
mentors to help us if you had jobs in
the past or maybe you're at a job right
now you probably don't have the greatest
leaders around you most people suck at
it
but it doesn't have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and can people
ask me what's my definition my
definition of leadership it's I want
people to win more than I want them to
win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Evan Carmichael video again
maybe you end up watching all my videos
and we end up being Partners on some
future business who knows you know we've
been seeing you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have have you ever heard the
expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
you know and hopefully that's our goal
for life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring
we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks it's more that you know you
don't have the skill set we don't have
the skill sets at the beginning to know
how to even find the right person let
alone manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work for overloaded with
work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right so familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time
it takes more time than it frees up
because you have to train them you have
to listen to them you have to care for
them you have to answer their questions
if you treat them like a robot or a
monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring firing are you going
to be massively frustrated and
overwhelmed and a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck in that cycle
where has this happened to you you hire
somebody you know looks great on paper
you're so excited for it to go and then
it doesn't work out a couple months
later and then you decide you know what
I'm just gonna do it on myself right I
know I can get it done I'm just gonna do
it all myself does that happen to you
[Music]
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you have a big mission it's just it's
just you cool go for it but if you've
got a big mission then it needs to be
team and that becomes a skill set that
you have to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that
and it's surprising how often you can
find things that support them and
support you not all the time I remember
having one guy in my team who his dream
was to be a baker
like what
I don't have an interest in opening up a
bake shop right but ultimately you
should you should leave us and go do
your passion because because I can't
help you inside of this job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about
so I gave him until the end of the year
if it was you know summer give him to
the end of the year to okay you're as of
the end of the year you you're out and
you have to go find a job I love you but
you have to go find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and it's
actually squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know he had to go and move on it was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn
copywriting or they want to learn how to
come up with good titles or they want to
learn
better communication skills if they want
to learn they have their list of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that some kind of
program some project something that can
also bring value to the company then
let's do it because when people are
working on the things that they feel
like they're growing in and they're
learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your
Exo business strategy hat on it's it's
great this is how Karma becomes
practical if somebody's engaged and they
feel like they're learning and they're
growing and they're improving you're
going to get the best of them versus you
have to feel bored and stuck and
learning nothing new right that's what
most people do in their jobs and
honestly the bar for leadership is so
low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody
like a normal human being and actually
have a little bit of care and compassion
and curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point
to then be able to say hey no I want I
want this person to have come out of my
organization whether that's in a month
or year 10 years from now a better human
because they were with us and it's
totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people and you want
to see them win
and you're responsible for making sure
that they get pushed outside their
comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need your environment is keeping you
where you are your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now the people you
listen to the media that you consume the
habits that you do daily all of them all
of them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years have said Evan you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened how do I get that
for myself right people wanted it
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over again so how did I get it
I've paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with it's
important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
the the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment you need to change it
because everything you're doing right
now is keeping you on the path that
you're on maybe there's been some growth
if you look at who you were five years
ago compared to now you've grown if
you're watching this channel you've
grown right you've made some changes but
is it drastic enough like are you proud
of where you're at look at where you've
come from in the past year two years
five years are you proud of where you're
at and are you comfortable with that
same level of growth for the next five
years if not if you think I want more I
want to help faster I want to have a
bigger impact faster quicker then the
fastest way to do it is to change your
environment so that's you I'm going to
give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is cut
out negativity just cut out the people
who don't serve you sometimes those are
friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the Friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they've
probably just stayed here while you've
gone out here
They don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that that becomes
toxic even if you're trying to be a
beacon even if you're trying to be the
person who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed this skin so that I can be
reborn like this is new skin none of you
that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
see I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life step number two is then
seek out optimism seek out positivity
seek out things that make you grow that
make you want to learn that make you
want to push yourself right I have my
channel that's really helped me that
every day I wake up and I'm surrounded
by positivity and optimism and belief
and things that drive me forward that
even if I've I've had a rough sleep or a
bad day or or whatever it might be I see
Steve Jobs right next to me staring me
down I have my parents behind me looking
at me encouraging me putting belief back
in me I've got videos to go to that will
build me up I've got my believe playlist
of music that I listen to that will
change my state and bring me back to a
place of optimism positivity what is it
for you
is it people do you need to be around
people physically can you go to meetup
groups can you go to the library or
coffee shop can you go join some
entrepreneur circles can you become part
of a co-working place can you be around
people
that that are positive that are
energizing for you or can it be your
physical environment right or can it be
your habits and your routines or can it
be the the media you consume what are
you consuming what are you watching on
TV
or on Netflix is it is it entertainment
are you just shutting off your life to
try to forget about your problems and
just be entertained or you're trying to
educate yourself to build a better life
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems in the world right now people
they have problems you have problems
most people choose entertainment as a
way to forget about their problems
instead of Education as a way to make
their problems better do you want to
shut off the world
and and laugh at somebody else's expense
and watch big brother and see man that
person's life sucks
or do you want to go build a better life
for yourself
most people don't want to do the work to
actually build a better life I hope that
you do because that's how you actually
end up being happy do you want to numb
it with drugs do you actually want to
build a better life for yourself and in
Step number three is scheduled for
success
schedule for Success so what are your
daily habits what's in your calendar
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold alive contagious you know optimism
what's the thing for me it's watching
videos for me it's going through my 5S
schedule so I start the day with singing
where I have videos that are on YouTube
that just their songs that make me want
to sing make me want to dance make me
want to move it's the fastest way to
change your state I wake up tired and
maybe low energy and then I put on music
and it and it changes my state and makes
me happy do that for yourself don't put
on music that matches your current mood
put on music that matches the mood that
you want to feel like and it's the
fastest way to just in a snap be able to
change yourself we all have music that
makes you bounce and come alive start
your day with that right that's part of
mine so singing then son I like getting
Sun uh going outside being in nature
just having sun on my face not just
being stuck inside all day especially in
the morning makes a big difference my
third s is sore so I want to do
something makes me feel bold and come
alive and for me where I love my phone
here but for me I share a message I want
to share a message you want to feel like
the work that I do has meaning and
importance so I think about somebody
that I helped yesterday and then I share
a message on Instagram and Snapchat and
put it up that helps me soar what do you
need for yourself then I sweat so I'll
do a quick workout and then I do
something to scare myself right now it's
doing
um cold showers so I sweat and then I
take a cold shower and it's like and I
do difficult things that's my morning
routine right I called the five five and
a half s rule because
some days I'll start with a snuggle with
my wife in bed so we're seeing if that's
going to become like a 6S protocol but
at least it's five and a half right now
that's what makes me come alive you
might need something totally different
I'm okay with that that's amazing maybe
you need to meditate maybe you need to
pray maybe you need to pet your cat what
is the thing that you need to do to make
you feel bold and alive and and then
schedule that in so that you're not
hoping one day that something happens
you're not hoping that you're gonna meet
the right person or hoping you're gonna
find the right video like demand
Excellence from yourself demand
positivity and optimism from yourself
every day because if you did if you were
bold coffin optimistic positive every
morning if you created that system for
yourself man what could you accomplish
in a year can you imagine
if you did something every morning that
made you feel bold and confident if you
felt bold and confident every morning
for the next year imagine the life and
business that you're gonna have it's
crazy it's wild right so you have to
create that you have to schedule for
success success will come from your
habits so look at your calendar what are
your habits and if you did these habits
would it lead to you becoming a success
nothing it happens until you do
something your life doesn't change your
business doesn't change your situation
nothing changes nothing changes that
means nothing gets better until you
decide to do something this is where a
lot of entrepreneurs get stuck is that
we're so obsessed with learning and it's
great learning is amazing and watching
videos is amazing and going to events is
awesome and reading books and learning
is just awesome but
it's easy to get stuck in our head and
feel like the fact that we learn
something got inspired got motivated is
enough
it's not enough until you go and do
something your life doesn't change until
you do something and so I've seen a lot
of people who who just seminar hop who
go from one person seminar to the next
person seminar to the next person
seminar and you go and you celebrate and
you write a whole notebook full of ideas
but then if nothing's changed in their
life and listen that's better than the
per than most people most people are
just trapped most people do not like
their life at all most people are not
investing anything in education and
learning and improving so at least it's
a step up from there but it's not where
you ultimately want to be
the difference in where you are now and
where you could be in a year two years
five years Etc is not just what you've
learned it's the action that you've
taken it's learning something and then
immediately applying and the ability to
be a fast starter and build momentum I
think will make an incredible shift
forward for you as a new skill to learn
this year so for example I just came
back from a crazy number of events I was
recording
a VR version of built to serve in
Arizona which was awesome and then I
went to two back-to-back events where I
was invited to be a guest speaker and
sit in on the events of uh one year to
pay 25 000 to be there and the other
he'd be a hundred thousand dollars to be
there the 100K event was a lot smaller
more intimate than the 25k event but
still highly successful entrepreneurs in
the room carrying a person development
lots of speakers and I had a binder full
of notes right as I learned something as
I want to apply something I'm writing it
down feverishly and
at the end of that week it was intense
you know I mean some of the notes
for example on my last day I went for
coffee with a guy who'd sold his
business for over 200 million dollars
and he picked me up from my hotel and we
went to his his compound not just his
house and spent a couple hours there and
then he drove me to the airport and
these are the kinds of people who were
at these events and so if you talk about
people who had built and sold
nine-figure businesses
there's a lot of wisdom there's a lot of
learning I'm trying to soak up as much
as I can and extract from his brain into
mine and and take as many notes as
possible and I remember sitting on my
airplane ride home
and just being one incredibly grateful
for all the awesome humans that I met
and the advice that I got and then
feeling overwhelmed I've got so many
notes just from this past week I've got
so many notes
I don't know what to do next
and so what I what I used my time on the
airplane there was no direct home
there's no direct flight home from
Phoenix to Toronto and so I had a lot of
airplane time and I used that time to
map out what I was going to do next
the worst thing you can do is just go
get inspired by anything with an event
the book a podcast a video you just get
inspired and then you fall back into
your regular routine you get so
overwhelmed by so many things and then
nothing happens you get excited but then
overwhelmed and then nothing happens and
you fall back into your regular life but
the best thing you do is take some kind
of immediate action so one of the things
as an example that this guy who sold his
business for 200 million dollars said
was have a single most important number
what is what is the most important
number that would drive your business
forward
and align all of your businesses around
that and so everybody on the team has a
has a single most important number
they're working towards and his
structure was most important number and
then the drivers underneath it and then
the action steps that you had to pick so
whatever you could Workshop it right now
think about what's the single most
important number for your business right
now what are the three drivers that then
make that up so to help get you that
number there's three things the most
important things that you can do to help
you focus and then underneath those
drivers are the action steps that you're
going to take this is his methodology
and I liked it I'd never heard of it
before I liked it
um he's writing the book on it and so he
gave me the first draft of the book from
able to be able to read and he said hey
I'm happy to hop on a call with you
um for two hours to walk you through the
process and how you can apply it to your
company whether you know it's you by
yourself you with Nina
we'll do a zoom together and I'll help
you through this like this is amazing
right like yes I love this
uh it's like when when can we do it he's
like I'm I'm busy and I'm traveling
whatever and so you know two and a half
weeks out
from when I left is when when we're
gonna do it I'm grateful and it's
awesome but that's too long
and so I'm of course not saying no to
being on the zoom and getting his wisdom
but I need to do something now because I
don't want to just I don't want to wait
two and a half weeks right like stopping
in the waiting business so
I just started so on the plane ride I
came up with my some most important
numbers for me and for the team and how
to organize it and then when I got home
I talked to Nina about it and we started
working it and planning it and creating
Google Docs around it and starting to
tell the team about it and restructuring
my meetings around it and making some
changes even though I don't have the
model I haven't talked to him yet we
haven't gone in deep we haven't done our
two hour session and I'm sure after we
talk I'm gonna have to make some more
changes too that he's gonna look at what
I did and say hopefully some of it was
right and that some of it was wrong and
I need to tweak it and that's fine but
the most important thing is that I took
some immediate action that I took this
binder full of notes and ideas that that
are inspiring but then got overwhelming
to say what am I going to work on when I
get home and
eighty percent of the things in that
notebook don't have to happen
right I think if you read a book you
don't need to apply everything in the
book you just need to apply something to
start making a difference if I have
every video that I make you just apply
one thing to your life and it makes a
difference for you that's all you need
right and so the willingness
to stop
learning
and and start applying
is is hard but is important the
willingness to put down a book if you're
reading the book and you're getting a
lot from it and you think of an idea to
apply to your your life your business
stop reading the book and go do
something on that idea
if you're watching a video listen to a
podcast you get it you get inspiration
stop the video stop this if something
came to you while I'm talking stop press
pause on the video and go do something
on that idea and maybe you never even
come back to the video cool you've done
something that's more important right
like where you are now to where you're
going to be in a year is going to be the
sum of the actions that you've taken the
inspired actions and the inspiration can
come from the books and the videos and
the conferences and podcasts and events
but just inspiration alone is not enough
it's the action it's inspired action to
go and do something and so it's
something I'm constantly reminding
myself of and
as you make your path down personal
development and growth and learning
entrepreneurship it becomes very easy to
get sucked into the Trap and let me just
quickly explain why when you're learning
everything is possible when you're at an
event or you're watching a video
everything is possible it's like yeah
man that's
create this and I can build that and I
could be up here and I can serve so many
people everything is possible and it's
such an exciting place to live in you
know that Visionary inside us that wants
to change the world and other people are
doing it and you're you're trapped
you're not trapped you're locked into
that zone and it's exciting right
everything is possible
and then when it gets to taking action
everything becomes scary
you're judging yourself for not being
good enough you don't know how it's
going to work out you're afraid the
first step is going to be a bad First
Step you're it's just all of the fears
and the doubts and the and the
insecurities come flooding back in and
it's easy to
eliminate all of that all of those fears
insecurities by going and learning
something else
like oh if I learned that then oh yeah
everything's possible again
right it becomes an addiction
we're addicted to the learning and
growing and the the knowledge
because it makes us feel good
but what you need to start getting
addicted to is the action is a service
right like get addicted to serving
people get addicted to helping people
and that will not come until you take
the ideas that you come up with and the
knowledge that you've figured out
and apply it
the best thing you can do whenever
you've learned something is to apply it
and I call it the two percent difference
what is the first two percent that you
need to act on
stop the videos put down the book
and just do something on the first two
percent expect it to suck expect not to
get results but build momentum
when you start building momentum when
you turn yourself from being a knowledge
machine into momentum machine that's
when you start serving that's when you
start helping that's when you start
building a life that you want that's
where the Fulfillment comes that's where
the money comes everything
is on the other side of taking your
knowledge and turning it into inspired
action burnout is real but I think most
burnout happens because people are not
doing the thing that they actually love
doing it's not just about being busy and
keeping your mind occupied all day you
can be busy and hate your life and get
burnt out if I was an accountant I would
hate my life and burn out in a day
because I don't like being an accountant
but doing this thing that I love I put
in way more effort way more work and I
love it it's been 10 plus years of still
having my YouTube channel and I'm not
burnt out if anything I'm pushing harder
than ever before because I love it and
so I think it's not just about being
busy it's about being busy on the thing
that is your mission for life now
compassion fatigue is a thing doing it
so much that you burn out yourself is
possible but again that is not why most
people are burning out most people I
believe are burning out because they're
spending too much time too much energy
too much effort doing things things that
they hate and if you wake up and hate
your life and hate the job you're about
to go to then there's no wonder why you
feel like you're burning out so I
recently came back from going to Tony
Robbins event in Dallas he invited me to
sit in the front row and uh super
blessed and grateful to have Tony
support and I went there with Alex
friend of the channel who helps me run
trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning of
every event saying hey I have some
friends of mine you might know them
don't be celebrities leave them alone
don't talk to them let them have their
own experience and it always makes me
sad when he says that because for me
meeting you guys meeting people who
recognize me and that's a group that I
over index because people who watch Tony
videos you know they're probably going
to find my content I like it I like it
more when people come and say hi it adds
to the experience for me and then on the
last day before we rushed out to go to
the airport I set up a meet-up right I
had an hour open before having to get to
the airport so let's do a meet up let's
do a local Dallas Richardson Texas
Meetup right and and it could have spent
the time doing something else or
sleeping in or writing my book or doing
anything else but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy I love it
hanging out with believe Nation gives me
more energy than it takes away and I
then took an Uber to get to my to the
airport and the guy who drove the Uber
was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I gotta start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one-hour Meetup
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
this is terrible and so I think it's
really important that you're doing work
that you love that would be a burnout
for other people but not a burnout for
you because you love it so much so how
do you find it how do you find the work
that you love I got a three-step process
called who I how I'm going to talk about
it in depth in my next book but let's do
a super quick analysis here to help you
guys who might be struggling step number
one is who so you're who is your most
important core value what is your most
important core value as a human being
mine is believe it's a one word most
important core value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you are unhappy with life it's
because you are living incongruently
with your most important core value so
someone whose core value is freedom as
an example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that I touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
believe I'm not going to be happy with
it so that just gives you already an
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises I think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who I
have step two is why so why is your
purpose your purpose comes in your pain
your purpose comes from the deepest
darkest most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what I'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing who you were X number
of years ago there's a lot of people who
are currently like that right now that's
who you want to help for Life that'll
never get old that's your purpose for
life I want to help entrepreneurs for
life I believe in entrepreneurs for life
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your wire and your who and
your why are constant they never change
your core values and your purpose are
for life and that's amazing the last
step is how who I how how is your
passion how is how you got out of the
pain that you're in so you struggled
with something how did you get out of it
you may not be fully out of it maybe
you're still on your journey out of it
but you're further ahead than you used
to be how did you get out of it did you
read books did you watch videos did you
meditate did you walk your dogs did you
listen to music like how did you get out
of it how did you get out of it and that
is a recipe that you can teach other
people how you got out of it was not
some random one-off situation you can
teach other people so I struggled a lot
with my business I felt worthless as a
human I wanted to quit I told my partner
that I quit how I got out of it was
modeling success I looked at Bill Gates
how he started Microsoft and I applied
those strategies to my business and we
started to see some success 20 years
later what am I doing still modeling
success right I want to learn from Grant
I want to learn from Steve I want to
learn from Kanye I want to learn from
these people it's why keep creating this
content how I got out of it was studying
success and now I teach other people how
to study success
right how you actually go about doing it
may change when I first started doing it
20 years ago is through books right now
it's through videos and in 10 years 20
years is going to be through VR and a
bunch of other technologies that I'm
sure are coming but
the how you got out is a teachable
recipe that you can give to other people
so if you're struggling with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process I
know of to get there figure out your who
your one where most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
to your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose standing up
has changed my life not
it up for myself and standing up for
what I might believe in and the the
standing up what is it it's not
metaphysical the the the theoretical I
don't know but but actually standing up
like the physical standing up
going from sitting down like I am right
now in my car but to standing up has
changed my life stand-up desks are now a
huge uh Trend and a huge boost and I
would definitely recommend checking some
of those out but when I first started
standing up was probably
wow I don't know maybe maybe 20 years
ago 15 years ago
I just found that when I was on the
phone and talking this is how it started
so I've been on I'm actually now on a my
office is a trampoline so I'm on a
stand-up trampoline desk I had to raise
my desk uh 10 inches so that the
trampoline could be underneath it and I
get 20 to 40 000 jumps a day on my
trampoline and went through three
trampolines last year because they broke
because most are not designed to be
jumped on that often but
trampolining while working might be a a
stretch for most people right now if you
ever see me and I'm doing an interview
and I'm on my main computer you might
see me
doing little micro bounces and I'm
trying to control it like hold it onto
the desk like don't bounce don't bounce
don't bounce because it can be it can be
annoying to watch on an interview but
for the most time I'm bouncing up and
down all day long on my trampoline now
why why did I start this well
15 20 years ago I just found that when I
was on the phone
and I was I was talking to clients I
would be better when I was walking
around
I don't know if it's a nervous energy or
what but when I sat down it was
less energetic less less like let's go
do this thing and when I when I stood up
it was just I had more energy
you test yourself do you have more
energy when you're standing up or when
you're sitting down and so on calls I
would I would not just stand up but I
would walk around I like to have
something going on I often people
comment on some of my videos where I
pitch it with my ring so my ring
whenever I'm thinking I like to be
I don't like to be meditative and still
I like to have something going on so I'm
often I'm often fidgeting with my ring
or you might see my ears move up and
down every now and then when I'm
thinking um I like walking around just
having something go and it helps me
think and process better
and so that was the starting point was
just okay cordless phone and walk around
then I discovered a stand-up desk I
forget who it was it might have been Tim
Ferriss
again way back in the day and the test
was not a full-on standard desk because
those barely existed but I took my
bookcase
and I cleared off the book with all the
books in the bookcase and I found the
shelf that was the kind of the best
height to put my laptop on and I just
tried standing there and I think this is
a good life hack not just for standing
up or not but just in general if you
want to try something
don't go off and buy the most expensive
thing and wait three weeks for it to be
delivered just go try something right
now
so if you want to try stand-up desks
don't go buy a stand-up desk don't do
that that's the worst thing you can do
don't spend a ton of money on a stand-up
desk and then wait three weeks for it to
be delivered to you
just take a bookcase or take some boxes
and put it at the right height and see
how it feels
you want to start a YouTube channel
perfect don't don't go researching and
spend weeks buying the gear and the
lights and the cameras and all that
stuff and it most of that most of the
stuff in these little experiments end up
failing and they now you bought all this
gear that's just sitting in your garage
you know your closet or your mom's
basement
the best thing to do is just start find
a small way to just get started and so
I stood up at my bookcase and the first
day I didn't last very long 20 minutes
40 minutes I it didn't last very long
when you're not used to standing up it
it's really hard it's like oh where I
need to sit down and after that first 20
or 40 minutes I got tired and I had to
sit down because my body wasn't used to
it but while I was standing up it's like
I really like this this is cool cool I
have more energy in just answering
emails and whatever else I was doing at
the time I had more energy so I'm gonna
try it again and that 20 minutes became
30 minutes became 40 became two hours
became four hours became six hours so
the point was like I could just stand up
all day long it became weird when people
came over to my office because there
were no chairs to sit down at so when
we're doing a meeting I'm standing up
and so they were standing up because
there were no chairs and it felt awkward
to have one person standing one person
sitting and then they start getting
tired because after 20 minutes of
standing up we got tired so I had to I
had to bring chairs back to my office to
host meetings and
um but that was the process that was the
starting point and it it turned out to
have all sorts of positive health
benefits and I had I had foot issues I
had uh the things that you put in your
in your shoes what's it called not
implants uh customized Souls whatever I
was going to a car like in my 20s I was
going to chiropractor almost every week
because my back was was a mess my knees
were were achy and cracking every time I
was walking like my body seemed to be
falling apart in my 20s I'm now 40
in May from 42 and my body is in better
condition than I was in my 20s
because a big I think a big factor is
because I'm on a trampoline all day long
instead of sitting all day long with
terrible posture and my body falling
apart now I'm jumping on the trampoline
all day long it's easy on my joints my
body I'm happy I have more energy and as
a result I'm healthier
the move to a trampoline came because I
was I was already standing up for
at least five years
uh maybe more and I saw Tony Robbins do
uh his his seminars and uh
backstage he would always jump before he
goes on stage Tony jumps a couple times
on his rebounder rebounder is just a
mini trampoline not like the giant
trampolines like what you have in your
backyard a rebounder is a mini version
of it that you can keep in your office
or your home or whatever he jumps a
couple times on his rebounder uh sprays
something in his mouth uh does like a
spin and then walks on stage
if you ever see him backstage that's
what he's always doing he jumps on his
trampoline a couple times puts something
in his mouth spins around goes out on
stage ready to go all right so that's
pretty cool I wonder what he's spraying
in his mouth uh and I like the whole
trampoline thing if I'm already standing
up why not get a trampoline and try and
so again what's what's the easiest way
to go off and do it well I I went to my
local Walmart and I bought a rebounder
and brought it home and
I had to adjust the height of my desk
and had to raise it beyond what the max
height was and the rebounder I bought
ended up breaking shortly after because
it wasn't designed to be jumped on that
often all day long every day right uh
but whatever it's fine Lessons Learned
right you figure it out you think do is
this worth doing or not
take the idea that you've got and try
because again the biggest thing that
most people are missing is just momentum
you're just not trying you have this
you've had this idea and we spend our
best energy planning it and ideating and
researching and what's the perfect
trampoline and what's the perfect
stand-up desk and you spend all that
energy researching and then tomorrow you
wake up the next week you come back or
the next month or whatever like nothing
has happened on it still
if all these great intentions but
there's not enough momentum
and so idea to action trust that your
ideas come to you for a reason and go do
something about them
and so go get the stand-up desk by
creating boxes in your office you know
go get the cheapest trampoline at
Walmart and just jump on it and see how
it feels
it's ended up changing my life so
I'm not used to sitting down anymore we
actually moved we just sold our place we
bought a new place and I moved uh into
one of the rooms as a temporary place
where we were showing our place because
my office backdrop doesn't is not very
conducive to selling the house most
people not used to a stand-up desk a
giant stand-up desk and trampoline and
all that and so I took my office down
because when you're selling a home you
wanted to appeal to everybody
and
I sat down for I don't know a couple
weeks while we were selling our place
and all of a sudden the back issues came
back I was cracking my back a lot my
knees started to hurt again my feet
started to hurt again my posture was
terrible again and I realized wow this
is why I stand up
so two lessons in this video the first
is try standing up
yeah you'll probably have more energy
you'll probably feel better it's
probably better for your health people
say sitting is the new smoking right so
try standing up and just give it a shot
and don't stress out if you get tired
after 20 minutes like I did the first
time through it's okay but do you have
more energy while you're working while
you're standing up and if so then just
keep going and just start with the
bookshelf for some bookshelves uh or
some boxes whatever just to get started
and the second lesson is is just do
something just momentum imperfect action
the ideas that you have in your head are
great they're genius you need to do
something you need to stop putting the
gas pedal on the energy that's flowing
through you the greatness is flowing
through you you're actively saying stop
stop stop do something find the smallest
possible way today today like right now
the smallest possible way to take that
awesome idea in your head and build some
momentum towards it
the only thing you're missing towards
your great life is the momentum focus on
one idea and make it work focus on one
business model focus on one Revenue
stream focus on one social media Network
and make it work so many times we're
focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and it's a result nothing
happens for all the people who are
telling you to have 13 different passive
income streams because if one goes away
you still have all these other 12. most
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month seven
dollars a month where instead if you
could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
build to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish if doing just this one little
piece of it feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether to social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself
so that I can quit my job if you have
one so that I can bring income in for
myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money but then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
even selling courses your own materials
and training and Etc and coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
should be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
getting paid immediately while we work
on the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service and a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
we just need to focus it's all possible
your big dreams are possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus honestly I think we're all
thinking small
you're thinking small I'm thinking small
we're all thinking small compared to
what what we're capable of and I think
we've been conditioned to think small
we've been conditioned by our upbringing
our family our our parents our guidance
counselors our teachers our
we've just been conditioned to think
small because we're learning about life
from people who
also never thought big and so because we
are products of our environment we have
conditioned ourselves to think the same
way as the people in our environment and
if you're not happy with your
environment and your environment is not
around around big people who've done
amazing things or thinking big then you
will stay stock thinking small as well
what I love about Naveen Jane is that he
thinks big you know the first time I
found this content there were three
people who
I get recommended all the time you
should do a top 10 on this person you
should do an Express on this person you
should profile this person and there
were three people who for the first time
upon first consumption of their content
really blew me away one was Denzel
Washington
uh if you have not seen Denzel
Washington you should go watch this top
10. he his backup plan for his life was
being a minister uh and he is a fire
presenter I just kind of a lot of times
we do actors it's really hard to get
anything good out of the interviews that
they're doing uh but Denzel Washington
is a whole other animal so he really
blew me away the second was Priyanka
Chopra uh who had a just amazing set of
interviews and super intelligent bright
woman and the third was Naveen Jane
where I'd like no idea who this person
is you should do Naveen Jane great go
look him I was like oh my gosh this
guy's amazing I want more Naveen Jane in
my life I think that's a great sign you
know like when you find people like that
even if you've never met them and up
until this year I had never met Naveen
Jane The Good Fortune I just recently
have him on on my channel to do an
interview in a collaboration but up
until that point I'd never met him
before and
when you find the people who make you
think bigger who make you feel more
confident to make you feel more bold
get around them more
this is my solution right I am trying to
hang out even if it's just virtually
with the people who inspire me to want
to play a bigger game you know either
those three people I haven't met Denzel
Washington
yet I haven't met Priyanka Chopra yet uh
and up until you know this year I hadn't
met Naveen Jane yet but I can still be
inspired by them I can still learn from
them I can still look at their content
and they can still push me to become
better
and I think
a lot of us stay stuck and stay small
because it's so
good to feel important
and we ended up being the big fish in a
small pond if you're watching this video
you are probably the one that's pouring
into
everybody else you're probably the most
optimistic person in your circle you're
probably the one who cares the most
about the people around you you're
probably doing the most for the people
in your circle and you're the one people
come to and say Hey how do I X you know
how do I grow how do I get better how do
I you're the one that's advising and
helping and pushing other people maybe
pushing them too much
that makes sense maybe you're maybe
you're pushing some people too much but
you're the most optimistic most
ambitious person in your circle probably
that's great in a sense and that you can
pour and give back and help others along
the way but who's pushing you
you know if you don't have somebody
pushing you to be better to be stronger
to be greater to be more ambitious to
think bigger than you probably won't
like if you it's really uncomfortable to
think bigger and if you don't have
somebody inspiring you pushing you
helping you then you probably stay stuck
and that's what we need to change and so
it's a message for you but it's a
message for me equally so and so step
one in doing that I think is just
changing the environment to be around
the people who do inspire you and
chances are most of the people who do
inspire you are not not people who have
you have direct access to and not people
who are taking on an intern you know
Warren Buffett's not taking on an intern
to go live with him for a year as far as
I know
so how do you do it well the easy way is
through content
I've learned so much you've been
inspired so much by just amazing people
through the content on my own channel
like I make these videos for me because
I need them because I need to believe
more in myself and then I share that
with you and thankfully enough of you
like it that I can make it a business
and hire a team and continue to make
even more content because if it was just
me then it'd be a lot fewer videos
coming up and a lot less profiles and a
lot less content
so being around the people and when you
find people who really speak to you who
really get you going who's like yes this
is exactly what I need then
be around them more subscribe to their
channels buy their books listen to their
podcast be around them more if they're
speaking an event go to the event
because it'll push you to reach another
level and this is why it's so great to
have so many people now I'm I'm
passionate about helping bring
new people onto the to platforms like
YouTube and getting their message out
there because some people
[Music]
will push you through things some people
will hug you through things everybody
has their own lens and you'll connect
with people in a different way so you
look at uh Eric Thomas so you look at a
Jocko willink or you look at uh Andy
frisella
who are going to be very in your face
cut right to the truth no BS no excuses
no wiggle room like get up and go chase
down your life now it's a hard push they
may be yelling at you they're very
intense it's a hard push forward and
there'll be other people like Oprah like
um brene Brown like Dave Meltzer who
have a different approach it's a much
softer approach they'll hug you through
it you know some people will push you
and yell at you to get through it and
some people will hug you through it a
lot of times the message is exactly the
same you know Oprah's message is very
similar to Eric Thomas's message the
difference is the delivery
Oprah will hug you through it and Eric
will push you through it and it really
just depends on what you need there's no
right or wrong it's just what do you
need and when you find the people who
give you what you need just be around it
more be around that more because no
matter how much you watch
one video
the impact will wear off right like
you're waking up tomorrow
the same person you were almost
yesterday maybe a half a percent better
but you could be you could watch this
video get all inspired be like yes all
right I'm gonna chase things down
amazing let's go and you have energy for
a few hours for the day but then you
wake up tomorrow and and that energy is
gone right has that happened to you that
energy suddenly is not there anymore you
don't feel as bold as courageous or
ambitious as you were yesterday why what
happened
it's not that there's nothing wrong with
you it's just normal
because you got an injection into your
environment that took you to another
level and then it it fell off
because there was no consistency in the
environment so you are where you
consistently do so whatever you want to
accomplish whoever you want to be to
consistently surround yourself with
people like that
because you're not getting enough in
your home environment your home your
environment now your life has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are it's allowed you to get to where you
are right now amazing and if that's
where all you want to be awesome
congratulations you've done it you've
you've hit the jackpot but if you want
more
then your current environment is not
designed to help you go and get more and
again I'm talking to myself just as much
as I'm talking to you like saying these
words out loud it's like what changes do
I need to make to my environment who do
I need to be hanging out with more
either in person or just through the
video content to make me want to push
more be more courageous save save
Bolder things and have bigger
aspirations and goals and dreams and and
take Boulder action towards
accomplishing them
right makes a big big difference and so
if you want to accomplish something if
it's business success or mindset success
then if it's just thinking bigger then
if you love Naveen Jane be around Naveen
Jane more
watch all his interviews and then listen
to any podcasts that he does and I did
one on my main Channel we'll link that
up at the end of this video you can go
watch if you want if you want to improve
your health and fitness and you're tired
of you know being on an Oreo diet okay
you can make a choice and decision that
I'm gonna I want to be this person I
want to be the person who works out I
want to be the person who takes care of
my body takes care of my health and
energy and that's awesome as a decision
but you need the environment to support
you and so now if you're subscribing to
health channels if you're following
people on Instagram who are working out
and take care of their bodies it will
make you want to live a healthier life
one of the ones that I love watching is
Tom bilyu and his health Theory show
where he's interviewing experts around
health and every time I listen I was
listening to one this morning every time
I listen watch it makes me want to be a
little bit healthier
you know the more that you're around
that kind of stuff the more you will
take on the mindset similarly if you're
injecting poison like if you're around
negative people or you're consuming
negative content and that's most of the
news and most of media to be honest is
mostly negative if you're surrounded by
negativity constantly and you're you're
watching negative videos and reading
negative news constantly you will be a
lot more negative you'll be a lot more
scared you'll be a lot more scarcity
mindset you'll be a lot more afraid
you'll be a lot less positive and
ambitious because that's what you're
feeding into your mind so be very
careful about now designing and
Engineering your environment your
environment has happened to you
you know you've had some control over it
but it's it's mostly happened to you
and now you can with intent change it
to be more positive if you had to ask
yourself if I wanted to surround myself
with the most positive encouraging
inspiring
people who will make me more courageous
bold and ambitious
who would those people be what would
that environment look like
and then make a choice
change it
change who you subscribe to change what
you're listening and watching
unsubscribe from all the channels that
make you feel worse about yourself
change your physical environment what
what clothes are you wearing what do you
put on the wall around you what's your
background on your cell phone and on
your computer you start to change it and
when you change your environment it'll
Force the change in your habits in your
mindset and in your
think big act small
think big you got a big dream a big goal
a big mission some big thing that you
want to get done that's where we love
being as entrepreneurs right we love
thinking about the big future and what
we could build and it is amazing and
exciting but it can also be overwhelming
it can be stressful it can be hurtful to
our own self-esteem because
tell me if this happened to you you've
got this big idea and big goal
and it's exciting to think about it but
then it also becomes scary and it
becomes impossible and it becomes
something that someone like you can't do
and then we get overwhelmed by the
details and then we can't
do anything about it because it feels
too big and to execute it we need a team
or we need venture capital and we need
investors and we need better people
around us and we need more skills and
all of these doubts and insecurities
creep in does that sound familiar is
that you
certainly is me
you know I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough
and anytime I think even close to that
scale it's instantly well how am I going
to do that
how am I going to do that I know we're
close
and so the thing that's really helped me
is think big but then ask them all
because the biggest thing that most
people are missing I'm missing you're
missing is just momentum biggest thing
we're missing is just we're not we're
not doing enough because thinking big
and having a big idea is amazing but
that alone is not enough you have to go
and you got to do the work and we're so
worried about the work being perfect
right you're so worried about the first
thing being amazing
and it won't be
and this is a hard lesson that I learned
when I was uh in my early 20s in my
first business and we lost a 40 million
dollar deal because I was trying to be
perfect
and I spent the whole summer working on
this perfect plane
and I lost the deal and I'm I'm a
recovering perfectionist and I think
seeing your perfectionist really just
means you're afraid right you're afraid
of it not being good enough you're
afraid of launching something and people
seeing it and judging you or you're
afraid of launching it and then not
seeing it nobody caring right we're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
both at the same time we're afraid I
said the answer is to do something
immediate action I've been helping
people in my movement makers program
get going on YouTube and now on Tick
Tock and the amount of indecision that
people have around creating their first
video
right what should I wear what should I
say what should I open the line be what
should my thumbnail be what kind of gear
should I use what kind of camera what
kind of microphone what kind of
fill in the blank right all the things
that just prevent you from taking action
where the answer is just film honestly
like just just get something up look I'm
filming this video on my phone walking
down the street
I didn't sleep that well last night
and uh getting some sunshine on my face
and just press and record and going
and I'm doing the best I can with what I
have and that's what you need to do is
just get it started because best plan
that you can come up with right now is
nowhere close to the plan that will help
you win
you know the plan that you come up with
right now is not going to be the one
that works because you don't have all
the information and so the idea that you
can plan
what the end looks like and the path to
get there is impossible and so we spend
our best energy
planning and thinking instead of
actually doing
it's a big problem
and so it starts with okay you've got
this big idea awesome now what are you
gonna do today about it today there's a
couple of hacks that I want to share
with you and I think can help so the
first is a two percent difference and
the two percent difference says instead
of planning for 100
you work on the first two percent so
what is that first two percent that's
all you need to work on what's the first
two percent so if you're thinking about
YouTube or making a tick tock if you're
thinking about a health Journey you're
thinking about
whatever it is for your business that
you want to launch what's the first two
percent
I just start building momentum so you
know if you want to make a YouTube video
go film a video just take out your phone
and film a video just like I am right
now do you want to get started on Tick
Tock cool same thing
flip your flip your phone the other way
vertical and start making your video you
want to start a health Journey cool
you know we get so stuck on
figuring out what The Perfect Workout is
going to be right have you ever done
this well am I going to do hit am I
going to do cardio how many weights are
going to do am I gonna am I gonna hurt
myself do I need to hire a trainer what
new equipment do I need to buy
you know we just get stuck in all these
planning mode instead of doing
just do anything just go for a walk
do five push-ups you know do a couple
burpees whatever whatever comes to mind
it doesn't matter what you do it's
matter that you're doing something
that's the big difference it doesn't
matter the specific action that you're
taking who matters that you're starting
to build some kind of momentum that
you're doing something
that's the most important thing because
if you
get up and you do something every day
you're going to find that you start
making some tremendous progress towards
things
and so two percent difference is to
teach yourself that you go from an idea
to some kind of immediate action that
we're doing something right away on it
we're not planning for 100 but we're
going for that first two percent the
next thing is just expect the suck at
the beginning
you know we expect to be great out of
the gate for some reason you expect your
idea to work you expect that you're
going to have the skills or who you
expect you're going to create something
amazing you won't just expect the socket
to start
it doesn't mean that you suck as a human
it just means that you don't have the
skill set yet and that's okay that's
normal and that's totally okay that's
fine
go back and watch my first video it was
pretty embarrassing go back and watch
anybody's first anything and it's and it
sucks
it's normal
so if you expect to be great and then
you try something and you can't do it
then you feel really bad about yourself
but if you expect it to suck and then
and then you're just anything above
complete
terrible sucking
then you're good then you've won
and so
apply the two percent difference
and then just expect to suck to suck at
the start and then you keep going
So for anybody there who's afraid to
take action who you know you have these
big Ideas big goals Big Dreams big
things you want to do
but it just seems so Out Of Reach and it
seems impossible and it seems that you
can't do it and it's never going to work
you know and you're stuck in
overthinking
over planning over estimating over just
over over just stuck in your head
and it's crazy how quickly we can go
from being excited by something
to then almost instantly overwhelmed by
it
you know and so you need to have the big
dream you need to have the big goal that
that should get you out of bed and
excited like yes this is the change I'm
gonna make in the world amazing and at
the same time you need a incredibly
small action plan just to get going
because you've got the great heart and
the big dream and the big mission the
only thing you're missing is momentum
finding your passion is one of the most
important and least understood things
that I think you can do especially as an
entrepreneur we've all heard the
expression find your passion find your
passion you got to do what you love and
from all the videos that I've done and
all the people that I've studied and
profiles whether they're entrepreneurs
innovators athletes recording artists
like whatever they are the number one
rule that they all have in common is
find your passion when I get asked
you've studied all these people what's
what's the most common thread that's it
find your passion you have to be doing
the work that you love
but how do you do it how do you find it
because most of the time we know what we
don't want right you know the life that
you don't want you know the people who
you don't want to be hanging around
you've been at some job that you do not
enjoy we typically know what we don't
want but we haven't done the work or
been given the tools to know what we do
want and that's what I'm going to cover
in this video for me I love helping
entrepreneurs I think your purpose comes
from your pain right so whatever you
struggle the most in life is what you
want to help other people through you
are built to serve so your purpose your
passion becomes a part of that will
definitely be in service to other people
somehow
it's not enough for it just to be about
you you have to be doing other things I
just came from doing some squats I feel
a little out of breath but it's amazing
I love this this is the best and so your
purpose comes from your pain your person
your purpose is to help other people
through something especially what you
want through yourself the passion
component though is actually enjoying
the work to get people to the other side
so for me I love helping entrepreneurs
I struggled a lot in my early days as an
entrepreneur and
I'm basically trying to make the world
of 19 year old Evans who are struggling
not struggle as much as I did and I'm a
visual learner so I'd much rather see
visual content than anything else
YouTube did not exist when I was getting
started and so I'm trying to share
whatever wisdom I have share the lessons
from other successful entrepreneurs so
that all of the 19 year old Evans out
there can learn and can improve and get
better
I have a process that I call the passion
process and if you go through this
process it'll help you identify your
passion
and give you a lot more light love
energy and money you know because we got
to make money as entrepreneurs so the
passion process is this if you want to
go through it make a list of all the
things that you've done to help other
people
especially the kind of people who who
are who you used to be like make a list
and I went through this process and
built a serve I did this with my wife to
help her find her passions this is where
it was birthed but if you just make a
list of all the things that you enjoyed
helping people with like you you got
them a result you're so happy that they
are now in a different spot because of
what you did like what did you do where
you showed up and you helped somebody
with something and just if you want to
pause the video you can if you want to
make a mental list just all the things
that you've done to help other people
okay
after you have that list
then write down or just circle the ones
that you actually enjoyed the process of
doing as opposed to just the end result
this is where we get stuck this is where
entrepreneurs get trapped okay we enjoy
the end result of what we've done but we
don't enjoy the process of doing it how
many times have you helped somebody else
out because you're a good person because
you're built to serve because you love
that person or even you see yourself in
that person and you just wanna you just
want to help and you're so happy that
you helped them
but you didn't actually enjoy the work
that you were doing and that's the key
difference the result has to be there
that you help somebody of course and the
thing that will make you light up come
alive love doing for the rest of your
life is the actual work you're doing you
love to so
bring it home that's some great Theory
awesome
in my example
example that I use in in build to serve
in my book is I love helping
entrepreneurs like I want to see you in
I every day I wake up and I try to
figure out what else can I do to try to
help entrepreneurs win how else can I
help the 19 year old Evans of the world
out there get their business off the
ground
and if you were to move your office say
you're going from a home office to you
got your first office it's like wow you
got your first place amazing and you
needed help moving I could help you move
and I would be so happy to see you in
your new office
the problem is I don't enjoy the process
of moving I don't want to unplug
computers and pack them in boxes and
move desks and sure it might be a fun
workout but I don't get lost in the
process of that right I don't love it I
love the end result of helping the
entrepreneur but I don't love the
process of getting the entrepreneur to
that result and that's the key
difference that's where most of you will
get trapped you love the end result and
feel like what you're doing matters and
is important great and you get that
little hit at the end like yes I helped
that person but did you actually enjoy
the process of you doing the work and if
not that's what we need to revisit most
entrepreneurs are doing too much of the
work that they do not enjoy just trying
to get to the result now not everything
you do is going to be amazing not
everything that you do is gonna is gonna
fill you up with joy and passion a lot
of running a business does suck and you
have to do things you know accounting
and taxes and legal stuff it's not stuff
that makes me come alive and I find
joyous but your goal as an entrepreneur
needs to be to spend more time in that
zone of Genius where you do actually
love it and at the beginning beginning
you know maybe it's 50 50 but hopefully
as you build and scale and grow and
learn more about yourself you can shift
the percentage of how much you do that
is in your zone of Genius that you love
doing versus what has to get done to
grow the business right and as you build
and scale and grow that's hopefully
where team comes into place to handle
all those things that have to get done
that you don't enjoy doing so if you
make your list of all the ways that you
have helped people if you have no idea
what's my passion you have no idea make
a list of all the things that you have
done that you've you've enjoyed the
result of helping somebody what have you
done to help people then Circle the ones
where you actually enjoyed the process
so I don't want to help entrepreneurs
move and pack boxes even if it leads to
a great result I want to do something
that I actually enjoy doing if you're
not happy right now it's probably
because you're not growing
humans want to grow we want to learn we
want to improve we want to get better we
want to feel like we're making
meaningful progress somewhere and when
we feel like we're learning and growing
and the work that we do matters we feel
great right if you felt great when you
learn the new skill when you when you
help somebody out when you felt that the
work you were doing was meaningful it
felt amazing
but if you have too many days in a row
or you feel like it's too hard it's too
big you're not growing you're not
learning there's
there's no hope
that leads down a really dangerous and
negative path not where we want to be
and part of why we become entrepreneurs
is because we want to grow right because
we're we don't want to have a crappy
boring job working for somebody else
wasting our talents away I remember my
my I didn't have that many jobs I had a
landscaping job which is super boring
just every day just rolling out grass
and then I had a data entry job
where this really turned me off of the
corporate world where
I was doing the work of
we had six people five people on my team
and I was doing more work than all of
the others combined
and I didn't take lunch breaks I just I
just kept working and my boss wasn't
happy that because I was overhead
lighting gave me headaches I used to
have to bring in some snacks like food
or popcorn or carrots or something so I
didn't get crazy headaches and my boss
didn't like that I was eating a snack
while I was working
and I got into trouble and almost got
fired
even though I was doing more work than
my entire team combined and it just
really
turned me off of the corporate world to
realize hey this is
this doesn't make any sense
I wasn't growing
you know I wasn't learning
I wasn't improving
and so you can examine your own life
if you feel like you're in a rut
chances are you haven't learned anything
recently
and so we can we can plan for this you
know you can change your schedule so
that you can focus on learning you can
put it into your daily calendar and
this is where I think it becomes the
greatest benefit my greatest tactic or
strategy for you for myself
is schedule in learning schedule in
growing
so for me it's my own videos you know I
make these videos
hopefully for you that you learn and
improve and something Sparks for you but
I'm making for me I'm making for me
because I need it because I need to be
around people who are doing big things
and that I know that every day there's a
video for me
you know it's it's going to be positive
it's going to be uplifting it's going to
spread believe it's going to be
motivational or inspiring it's going to
be Tactical
and I know that on my channel I'm going
to get content that I want
and so I've hired a whole team and built
the whole business basically around
making content that I want to watch and
thankfully enough of you guys want to
watch it as well that it it I can build
a business and have a team
but if I didn't or nobody else cared
about it I would still do it for me you
know it may not be as fancy may not have
as much intros and all that stuff but I
would still have it for me because I
need it and so
we tend to catch these things too late
because it's not part of our habits and
routines so if you notice you go to an
event or you watch a video and you get
all inspired and you're you got energy
and you're working and things are
amazing cool and then
have weeks or months gone by and you
realize what happened to me what how did
I fall off the horse so quickly where
did my energy go has that happened to
you
chances are is because it wasn't
scheduled
you know part of the entrepreneur roller
coaster is because we're bouncing from
one high to the next
without having any scheduled in learning
and growth
and so
my challenge to you would be to try to
figure out how can we schedule in
learning and growing every day
and so it starts with figuring out okay
what medium do you like the most you
know for me I like videos I like being
able to see stuff it just makes it so
much easier for me I'm a visual learner
before YouTube was a thing I learned
from books that was the best thing
available at the time now I still have a
habit of reading 10 pages at least a
night but I don't get most of my
learning from books I get most of my
learning from videos but for you maybe
it's videos if you're watching this
maybe it's books maybe it's podcasts
something like where do you get the best
learning and then the great thing about
where we are right now is there's so
much content there's so many people to
learn from there's so many people
creating
things out there that you can go and
learn from them
you know if I look at an Eric Thomas or
an Oprah Winfrey they have a similar
message just a different delivery style
and so whatever you want to learn
chances are somebody's already making
content on it
and so just go and find them and think
about who you're following right now
like do an audit of who you follow right
now we fall in on YouTube we've fallen
on Instagram or Tick Tock or what
podcasts you listen to or what books are
you picking up
and how many of those people that you're
following are subscribed to actually
make you feel
ambitious and hopeful and better about
yourself and give you strategies and
light you up and feel like you're
learning and growing right that's the
whole point of this we're trying to make
growing and learning a consistent habit
so how many people that you're following
actually make you want to learn and grow
and how many of them are you just
mindlessly scrolling through you know
when you load your Instagram or your
YouTube when you're just scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and two hours
have gone by and
not only have you not learned anything
you feel worse about your life because
now you haven't been productive
you know you just kind of mindlessly
entertained yourself but it wasn't even
that entertaining because what just
happened to the past two hours of my
life has that happened to you cool
unfollow those people
it's not that they're bad people
because that content doesn't light you
up
and then start to be around the people
who do
and the easiest way is through content
so if it's my channel hey good news
we've got content every single day for
you you'll never run out of Evan
Chronicle content to watch but it could
be somebody else it's somebody else in
marketing or business or
entrepreneurship or person development
or whatever category you're in
to subscribe to those people and be
around them as much as possible and
watch your videos every day schedule it
in for me I go for a walk every morning
call them I believe walk I just like
getting some sun on my face and fresh
air and getting out of the home and it
just gives me some perspective and a
little bit of motion and helps me set up
my day and then I'll have a video going
for my channel
and um every morning will be somebody
else it'll be
Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Mel
Robbins or Tony Robbins or garyvee or
Tom Billy or whatever and that's what we
do is pull the best clips that I would
learn from and then we share it with
everybody else but that's a part of my
daily routines and I've I've seen my own
growth and development and learning and
bravery and courage and momentum and
consistency
be directly contributed and correlated
to
the content that I'm consuming daily
and so step one is to unfollow and
unsubscribe from the people who just
make you waste time feel worse about
yourself get Envy
or just mindlessly tune out
and step two then is to figure out
I need to make learning you need to make
learning growing a part of your daily
habit and so where in your calendar can
that fit
if it's over breakfast if it's a morning
walk if it's a afternoon lunch like
where in your calendar can you put
learning from your preferred Style video
podcast books Etc learning into your
daily calendar if you did that your life
will change if you did that every day
for the next year every day if you did
that if you scheduled that in and you
actually did it and you you watch your
video write a book or listen to podcasts
that inspired you said you know what I
can do this I can do more I can be more
I can accomplish This I Gotta stop
thinking small and stop doubting myself
and stop telling myself that I suck and
I can't do it I can't do this like if
you felt that energy every day from
watching a piece of content that you
intentionally put into your habits
routine every day for the next year
your life will totally transform
you will be a totally different person
which then allows you to serve more to
help more to make more money to guide
more to be a leader more all of it all
of your Ambitions and dreams everything
that you want
is all possible
but you have to factor learning and
growing into your daily consistent
habits and routine when you have a why
to live for you can endure almost any
how it's one of my favorite quotes if
you think about it if you've got a
strong why most people are stuck on the
how how do I do this how do I get
started how do I write a book how do I
create a video how do I get my first
client how how we're stuck in the land
of how but the problem for most people
is not the house is the why is the
strong enough think about the time where
you really had to figure something out
you really had a strong one like this
this must happen we've all had those
moments you figured out the how the how
now maybe didn't come right away the how
you might have tried 18 different things
before you found the how but the how was
often when you say you're stuck on the
how it's often just an excuse because
you're you're afraid
that I want to start a YouTube channel
cool how do I do it and and you're stuck
on what gear to use and what microphone
and what topic and you know whatever
whatever the typical questions people
have that probably run through your
brain that ran through my brain when I
first got started too right really
what's underneath that is just fear
it's just fear it's like fear that
nobody will watch the videos people fear
that people will watch the videos and
you'll be judged it's just fear
if you're stuck on the how it's just
fear talking this is an important
Insight if you can apply this to your
life will make a huge difference if
you're stuck constantly on the how
it's just fear talking and this is your
logical brain guiding you through the
process of staying stuck
I can't tell you how many people I've
helped and given them the house just
here's how you do it here how here's go
and then there's another question
another question another question and no
action because it's fear
and so how do you get over the fear know
how it's going to take you to the fear
fear is the why you solve the fear to
the why why must this happen why is this
so important why are you doing this and
it's a constant reminder of why because
you can feel super motivated and excited
today but then wake up tomorrow and kind
of lose sight of the why
I think it's important to apply in three
areas one for yourself two for your
clients or customers the people you're
helping sell to
um and then three for your team as you
build and scale the company so let's
break down each one
um for yourself
why do you do what you do you know if
you're a solo entrepreneur or you've got
a small team when you're building why do
you do what you do why is it so
important that you wake up and show up
today because you don't have a boss
there's nobody who's gonna fire you if
if you don't show up and and do your
work right
part of a structure of a corporate
environment and having a boss breathing
down your neck and you know you're going
to have a performance review and you
know that your your next paycheck is
dependent on you doing well right sure
we have our customers as our bosses but
a lot of times entrepreneurs a little
slack off we'll find reasons why not to
do something we'll convince ourselves of
you know why we're not capable and why
this is not a good idea for us to work
on
you know but we're not we're not focused
enough daily consistently on the why of
what we are doing that forces us into
momentum growth and action here it's a
it's a Tuesday morning as I'm filming
this video for you guys right now I've
got a lot of videos to film I've filmed
you know thousands of videos over over
12 000 videos I should do account
because I reference it but I don't know
how many like thousands and thousands
and thousands of videos
and it's
easy just to get in the car and film a
video
but what's important is the connection
to the wire I'm I'm sitting in the car
or driving to do
some errands and
it's a exercise to remind myself why I
do this because you guys are watching
because I want to help solve the world's
biggest problem because I want to make
content for a 19 year old everyone who
didn't believe in himself because in
learning from people like Elon Musk it
encourages me to think bigger and push
harder and do more and I'm not just
sitting in my car talking into my cell
phone
I'm doing life-changing work you know
and it's that it's that daily reminder
and and then I'll feel that and I'll
press record and here we are making this
video you know right now
and then tomorrow I'll need I'll need
another reminder
at least it works that way for me
it's not that I can just watch one video
or go to one event and then I'm I'm I'm
good for the next year
it's it's a daily not struggle but a
daily you know just like you have to
brush your teeth every day
it needs to be a daily habit or you
won't remember it but it's important to
remember because when you feel your why
and you feel like what you're doing is
at least on the path to having an impact
on people you just show up with a lot
more energy and care and kindness and
and drive compared to if you feel like
well it doesn't really matter if I show
up today or not so that's the first one
is you building in the habit of
connecting to your why on a daily basis
to give you more energy to push forward
and do the courageous things that you're
afraid to do so you don't get stuck on
the how how's not the problem you're
just afraid
number two is the why for your customers
one of the biggest advantage that you
have as an entrepreneur is
your story like why would I buy from you
instead of buying from your big
competitor that that I've known for
years or some big brand name why why buy
from you why buy from you know the
little guy well your story because I
feel like you care because I feel like
you have a strong why if I'm if I'm
buying from you instead of Coca-Cola
why would I buy your drink well because
you have a strong wine I don't know what
Coca-Cola's Y is people aren't connected
to the brands that they buy from for
their wine
is how you win and so you sharing your
story and why you do what you do becomes
really important one of the best pieces
of feedback that I get is on my website
and on the website if you go to Evan
carmichael.com if you want to check it
out
I share my story and I share why I do
what I do so it's not just another guy
making some content on YouTube and you
know on various platforms but you can
hopefully connect with the reason why I
do what I do and people read that and
then they they want to dive deeper into
my world and the same thing can happen
with you you don't just sell a product
or service don't just try to make you
yourself look like some
giant Corporation and be professional
like like yes you want to be
professional but your story is the thing
that carries a day the most your story
sharing it why you do what you do really
really really really matters because if
customers can connect to your story
they're much more likely to know you
like you trust you want to buy from you
want to do business with you because
they feel something in your story that
hit someone on an emotional level that
will then use to justify why we're doing
it right again it's it's our emotions
and our heart leading the way and it's
our brain convincing ourselves why we
have to do it customers if they like
your story
and it made them feel something
emotional will find a way to justify
working with you to convince their brain
that it's a smart idea
but it's really an emotional decision so
the first why is for ourselves second
wise for our customers and the third why
as you scale and girls to the team so
we've got 37 people on the team and one
of the hardest things
um
that I've that I've noticed as we as we
grow and scale is making people's
individual work
feel like it's contributing I'm a little
spoiled in that
I get to see all the great stuff I get
to meet you at events and conferences
and I get to hang out with you in Movie
Makers and I get to see the comments and
I get to your people want to take
selfies and I get to see a lot of the
good stuff but this is a team effort you
know if I wasn't if I did not have my
team this would not be happening I may
be not making this video for you right
now because I have a million other
things that I have to do and run a solo
business
one of the things that I found really
helpful in my business is
every Sunday I connect with somebody
else on the team so there's some people
I meet once a once a week that are you
know Mission critical but there's other
people now as we scale and go to the
team but there's not enough time to meet
everybody one-on-one once a week uh and
so what I do is I I reserve Sundays
for connecting and trying to really
deeply connect with somebody on the team
this weekend I I connected with a new
member on our team who's helping do a
lot of the research for these videos and
finding the clips and putting them
together and bringing them to me to be
able to record and
it's one thing just to have a job and
the the the bar for being a boss is so
low you know to to be a good boss really
just have to not treat people like crap
honestly like most people have bad boss
experiences so just care about people
and you're already creating the best
experience probably in their work
history but I don't think that's good
enough like I don't think that is I
don't think it's a good enough
experience I think people should feel
like they're showing up to work and
they're doing something that matters and
so it becomes your job to connect the
work that they're doing to something
that matters so back to you know my week
my meeting on the weekend
uh this person who's been doing a lot of
great research for us it's it's easy
just to look at what she's been doing
and congratulate her on finding Great
Clips and
um just telling her what a good job
she's done and that's worthwhile for
sure
but what's the why
is the why to just not get fired is the
why to get a raise as to why like what's
the why driving meaning behind her work
and want to make sure that people on the
team feel meaning behind the work and so
my job as a leader is to connect
the work that she's doing to the end
result so that if we see people leaving
great comments on the video we see
people making life-changing decisions we
see people growing their business that's
a that's that's you like you did that
you helped do that
and we often as entrepreneurs forget
that so if you built and scaled a team
even just one person on your team
somebody doing usually who's the first
person to hire somebody to do admin work
typically right
they're very behind the scenes and so I
think it becomes your job to then show
the person who's working behind the
scenes how the work that they're doing
is leading to a Major Impact if you're
up front and you're getting all the
accolades and you're doing the speeches
and you're getting the books and you're
making the videos and you're doing the
Selfies and people are telling you how
amazing you are cool
it's great I mean it it feels amazing
and then think about how can you bring
that back to your team as well and let
them know that they're a part of this
that they created something meaningful
because I think when when you can when
they can attach meaning to their work
they're just gonna be they're gonna be a
lot happier they're gonna give you a
better result they're gonna
they're gonna have more connection to
the work that they're doing and they
feel like they're living out their
purpose as well not everybody wants to
start a business but everybody wants to
feel like they're doing something
meaningful and oftentimes people are
that just haven't made the connection
because you as a leader me as a leader
we haven't done a good enough job in
showing them the impact that their work
is having so the why becomes everything
when you have a strong enough why you
can overcome and endure anyhow
if you're stuck in the house because
you're afraid how you get the courage to
push through figure out a strong enough
why and if you consistently tap into
your own why if you consistently show
your customers why you're doing what
you're doing and if you consistently
show your team
the why of the impact that they're
having I think that's a recipe for
Success the toughest way to fulfillment
is to feel like the work you do matters
at the end of the day everybody is built
to serve and write a whole book on it
you are built to serve you want to feel
like today matters that you're going to
wake up and you're going to create
something today that will mean something
to some people to someone maybe it's a
million people maybe it's one person but
you're gonna make something that will
mean something to somebody look at me
I'm sitting here in a parking lot my
wife is shopping at a food store and I'm
sitting here in the car with my my dogs
passing out on my phone making a video
why
because I feel like this matters
I feel like somebody's gonna watch this
video and it'll make a difference for
them and hopefully that's you maybe not
everybody but at least one person will
watch this video and it'll matter and
it'll mean something
s
and when I feel that I'm much more
likely to show up I have more
fulfillment I have more energy I have
more kindness I have more love I have
more motivation and when we feel like
what we're gonna do doesn't matter makes
no difference nobody cares if we show up
or not that's the path down to anxiety
and stress and overwhelm and depression
and suicide this is where most people
are at most people do not like their
lives most people feel like what they do
does not matter
I think most people wake up and they
drive to a job that they hate and they
feel like today it doesn't matter nobody
cares if I show up or not the work I'm
doing doesn't really have an impact and
that's why a lot of people move towards
entrepreneurship is because we're
looking for more fulfillment because we
want to feel like this thing we're gonna
do is gonna make an impact and at least
somebody's life and if you can run some
of those things together you can have a
couple days even in a row feeling like
this matters
and the energy difference that that will
be inside you the motivation will change
the kindness will change how you show up
for others will change how you talk to
yourself will change all because you
feel like the work you're doing today
matters they did
functional MRIs on people's brains and I
talk about this and build the serve they
did functional MRIs in people's brains
to see what parts of the brain light up
when we're helping people when we feel
like we're gonna do something that's
even just a small act of kindness
and it lights up the same part of the
brain as having food and having sex
serving others
the same part of the brain is having
food and having sex
we're hardwired to do it if you're not
happy right now is because you feel like
you're not serving that you don't matter
you might be doing stuff that matters
but you feel like it doesn't matter this
is where I get stuck on goals people say
what are your next goals I don't know
five million subscribers 10 million
subscribers it doesn't it doesn't mean
anything what does that mean
it's more the qualitative stuff that
means the most to me it's the comments
that you guys leave on the videos it's
the people that come up to me at events
and tell me how much the content has had
an impact on their lives like that's the
juice that's why we do what we do
and of course you have to get numbers
and of course you have to drive revenue
of course you have to like all of that
matters because in making money it
allows you to go and create more and
serve more and help more you know and
build a better life for yourself as well
um money is definitely important it's
got to be your top five but it can't be
number one
and number one is feeling that you're on
a mission
that you're going to make something
today that will matter so how do we do
it
again I go through the process and build
the serve but basically three steps it's
who I have so who is your single most
important core value when you get the
guess what is your most important
program what do you stand for as a human
being
means belief so I want to spread belief
everywhere that I go in this video my
intention is a spread belief I want I
want to believe more in myself and I am
hoping that you believe more in yourself
as a result of being around the stuff
that I make I don't always accomplish it
but it's the intention it's the goal
always going in and
whatever your most important core value
is that's what you still need more for
yourself it's your biggest roadblock
right now and it's also the gift that
you want to give to the world to the
people around you you want to help them
feel X as well for me it's believed what
is it for you step two is your why and
your why is your purpose and your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggle the most with is the thing
you want to help other people through so
I struggled so much as an entrepreneur a
young entrepreneur or 19 or 11 quit on
my business partner didn't think I was
adding any value no contribution not
getting any results working my face off
but just getting zero results no
traction and I hated it I hated it so I
quit on my business partner
I went back the next day but that was
that was
man the worst day of my life and
my why is to help other entrepreneurs
not struggle as much as I did whatever
you struggled with the most is a gift
because you're going to help other
people not struggle as much as you did
and that will make you feel amazing
forever we all love helping right back
to the functional MRIs you love helping
you love assisting you you'll you'll buy
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or open the door for somebody or
you'll help somebody pack their car with
groceries or help somebody up who fell
on the street or something you'll do
that it'll you'll feel good
um but that's a little momentary Thing
versus if you felt like
there's somebody who you're helping who
was a younger version of you you see you
in that person
and you help them come alive by talking
to you by spending five minutes with you
you see hope light up in their eyes that
wow maybe I don't have to stay stuck
maybe I don't have to struggle and
suffer as much as I am because they met
you
and that's a totally different vibe and
feeling that's that's the thing to get
addicted to get addicted to serving get
addicted to helping get it get addicted
to impacting you know what a difference
it makes and so figuring out your why
becomes really important because well
often
uh just find ways to
try to find any kind of meaning without
ever ever having done the deepest work
and as entrepreneurs we struggled to
often looking back I don't think about
my most painful moment that was in the
past I don't want to touch that I want
to be happy not to miss it and move
forward well this is how you do it right
the point of looking back at your most
painful moment is not to live there it's
to say there's lots of people who right
now currently are struggling with the
thing that you struggled with before you
can help them and you'll you'll light up
you'll be the greatest thing of all time
to help those people so first is your
who your most important core value
second is your why which is your purpose
and the third is then your how and
that's that's your passion so how do you
want to help people so how so I want to
help people believe in themselves and
especially entrepreneurs because that's
what that's where I struggled the most
but how do I do it well however you came
out of the hole that you were in is a
teachable thing that you can give to
other people so for me it was model and
success and that's it who has done this
before and I studied them and I applied
that lesson as Bill Gates applied this
lesson to my business and we started
having success now what have I done for
the past 20 years is teach people how
they can model success to the situations
in their business of their life to
accomplish their goals so how did you
get out of the hole that you were in
what was the thing that you did and
where we get trapped a lot is we love
helping people to get the result but we
don't love the process of helping them
so the classic example I use if you're
moving your your your office I love
helping you as an entrepreneur move to a
new office but I don't want to help you
pack boxes and pack up computers right
so I like the end result of helping you
believe in yourself and you've launched
your new
office awesome but I don't like the
process that leads up to it so we're
constantly chasing the result but we
don't enjoy the process we're the number
one rule for Success if you have to
enjoy the process and so we get givers
we get trapped in this Loop of
constantly helping people because we
love helping people we feel good helping
people and we get the result of helping
people but we don't enjoy the process
and so we never get actually great at
the thing or world class because we're
not enjoying the day-to-day work and so
that becomes the next challenge is
however you got out of the hole that you
were in is a teachable thing to others
and we have to enjoy the process of
doing it so it doesn't feel like work
write that whole expression of find what
you love and you'll never work a day in
your life it's true you know I I love
making videos how have I done so many
videos for so long so consistently
because it doesn't feel like work this
isn't this doesn't work I would you know
my wife is in in this store here you
know shopping for for food that feels
more like work than sitting here in the
car and making a video for you guys
right and so there's no right or wrong
you know for for my wife she'd probably
rather be in there than making videos so
for you what's the process that you
actually enjoy that is contributing to
other people so when you can combine all
those things when you can
find the thing you love doing that's a
service to others that is helping people
who currently are who you used to be in
injecting them with the core value that
you've got that you still need even more
for yourself that's when everything
starts to shift so the who I help
process who who sing the most important
core value why your purpose your purpose
comes to your pain and how
is your passion how you actually want to
help people
with their you know through your who and
in your why
figure that out everything gets easier
everything gets more exciting everything
gets happier everything you feel more
grateful more confident More Alive more
momentum you start making more money
it's like you stop fighting the world
and you start flowing with it
because you want to serve and you've got
so much kindness and opportunity inside
you that needs to come out that where
you are right now is not it's not where
you want to be it's not where if you
fast forward a year two years five years
you want to be in a better
spot
everything wise health-wise emotional
gratitude money in your bank account all
of it and it's and it's possible when
you can connect your who your why and
your how to find a fulfillment that
you're after
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there make your calendar your life this
is how you start to live in intentional
life because you've designed it you've
put it in your calendar not just the
business things when we think about a
calendar it's usually your business
stuff okay I got a meeting here